le blocage aujourd'hui est présenté par
paul islip une marque québécoise de
matelas et d'oreillers et de produits
pour dormir
c'est un des commanditaires de od chez
nous cette année
alors les caisses de d'expression double
peau péage sur de cette année auront
l'occasion de dormir sur cimade
merveilleux matelas puis tu parles de
dormir depuis tantôt mais ils vont faire
beaucoup plus que dormir sur les
matelots police les on l'espère j'aurais
vraiment aimé savoir les mettre la
police liban un code promo pour vous
autres qui le ssf 25 qui valide jusqu'au
28 septembre qui est surtout excepté les
semis donc on va mettre le lien pourra
les utiliser ce code promo là et pour
augmenter la qualité de votre sommeil
tous les activités extra curriculaires
lors de votre rentrée scolaire qui est
en cours moi je dors avec des guerriers
police l'ip depuis un bon bout piste un
client satisfait très satisfaits essayé
d'être aussi ce shakedown par vos achats
brive ça marche et je leur posais des
marques barbie le guide or lose a aucune
dérive qu'on est bien ensemble gates
dans l'est je dormais à et cheikh issa
dans la gestion du podcast bon paquet
production du f bienvenue au sans fil
très le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter date si tu cherches
qu'antec mois dôme plantes c'est mon nom
est abonnée voix de pétrole pourrait
progresser la version nous encourager
on à du contenu exclusif à préchac
podcast on parle un petit ventre en
milieu de la conversation convient
d'avoir à chaud avec nicky en plus
nicole notre technicien extraordinaire
qui vient d'intervenir pendant les
podcasts piquionne fake abonnez vous un
match en les informations sont dans la
description cette semaine un podcast
très spécial c'est bien ça bosse
castaing pas de casque pardon spéciale
on reçoit mon frère mon fera ça fait
longtemps considère maintenant on va où
va le recevoir au tpiy le c'était le
moment un mot frac et réalisateurs de
films et son tout dernier nouveau film
sera en salle au moment où ça va sortir
ça va sortir dans quelques jours donc
dans un cinéma près de chez vous il faut
aller voir ça s'appelle nadia barfly
c'est l'histoire d'une athlète olympique
aux olympiques qui fait sa dernière
course en carrière qui vit toutes sortes
d'émotions par rapport à soi pas avoir à
sa retraite qui s'en vient c'est
vraiment un très beau film nous on les
écoute est vraiment récemment en fait on
n'avait pas vu ont certaines projections
d'equipe puis en fait le podcast a été
tournée le lendemain de cette projection
d' équipe le avec pascal m'ont frappé
avec aussi les deux actrices principales
du film
ariane minville et katerine savard qui
sont deux athlètes en fait de niveau
international devrait nageurs qui ont
qui ont appris piquant qui ont joué la
comédie qui ont joué qui ont des actifs
dans ce film là en plus de danger c'est
un très beau film qui on a plongé
vraiment dans le film peut-être que pour
certains en fait je t'encourage vraiment
aller le voir puisque les autres le sol
si vous écoutez le film c'est certain
vous allez apprécier les podcasts deux
fois plus est plus comprends parce que
on décortique un peu les seins on en
parle
puis même sur la vie pauvre ben j'espère
ça vous donner envie d'aller le voir je
pense à vraiment la peine
puis c'est assez incroyable ce fait
mieux en fait été sélectionné au
festival de cannes cette année ce qui
est immense qui vraiment dans le monde
du cinéma
le
le plus grand honneur en fait le plus
grand honneur qu'on peut avoir
donc c'est très excitant ce qui se passe
avec ce fameux là puis je vous invite à
aller le découvrir puis apprécié sa
conversation là avec trois personnes
vraiment extraordinaire puis à tiques
comme 2010 le film c'est vraiment un
film qui est proche de nous autres ouais
parce que c'est un milieu auquel on a
évolué et moi je joue dans le film je
suis également acteur j'ai quelques
lignes de dialogues y est mais en toute
honnêteté
si on peut utiliser notre tribune pour
essayer de mousser la promotion de ce
film là on vous invite grandement les
lois au vrai ça encourage le cinéma
québécois ça encourage pascal frère de
john williams et ami depuis depuis aussi
longtemps que je le rappelle puis les
deux faits en fait catherine à rien et
toute l'équipe du film donc c'est ça
dans le fond écouter cette conversation
là puis aller voir le film
hier au podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
par oliech première c'est commencer ses
actions
pascal rien catherine et what's up
allemande en famille on vient d'
excellent film ouais c'était comment
pour des devis seul
est-ce que vous avez plein oui ouais
ouais j'sais pas dire calme et j'ai
pleuré c'était dans l'est dans les 25
premières minutes 5.5 triste jeu très
bon mexique ainsi qu'un nadi a fini sa
carrière pillé des larmes gym c'est de
me chercher parce que ça peut projeter
l'expérience qu'on est un homme variés
comme les feux des c'est vraiment il ya
un an c'était t on tournait vois-tu
béteinou on a embarqué après c'est son
ensemble quoi genre printemps 2010 9 kg
et s a déboulé et on a tourné vraiment
ses seules ou septembre tokyo la portion
à tokyo en octobre
ce scénario là ça faisait longtemps
qu'ils dorment est on contourne c'est ça
ce que moi je vais à perte m'avait
envoyé une version forking criminelle le
longtemps voire je pense que tu m'en
parler tu m'as pas baissé en mai tu m'en
parler avant que j'allais occupation
debout et non non ça se met d'ailleurs
c'était nous on se connaît depuis
l'europe et https choc dans le film
s'était pas de barbe comme ça te
c'est peut-être au niveau ph aucun point
d'en face je suivais pour un gant
natation c'est là mais en seulement
seront donc tous les crimes et ça
faisait longtemps que je me suis élite
et enfin de natation le stade de rouiba
clés qu'on louait qu'il réclame dans le
sous sol chez nous et 36 millions et
encaissements que je nageais encore
n'ont peut-être pas moi j'ai arrêté de
nager après les essais de beijing 2008
ça que m'est et je te dirai ça petit
trop long j'ai fait trois ans de
concordia de bach
mais après ce délai court métrage sur
puits mais mon premier long métrage la
première idée pour un long métrage qui
s'est un peu chez paix dans ma tête
c'était vrai [ __ ] plus sûres mais
c'est un film de natation à cette époque
là c'était canadien s'était pas mais
qu'il y avait aussi à manifester en
lisant je pensais c'était au tour des
jeux de londres des pays commencent à
voter les articles de jean ray le nombre
de condom qui distribue dans le puits
ce à quoi un pij et comme fait un peu un
peu le soir mais encore une fois c'était
super prototype hybride fait maintenant
que fait lui après les faux tatouages
par exemple la vraie réponse c'est que
pour celui là il y avait besoin de plus
un budget plus substantielles c'est
comme il ya un genre d'escalier t de
déchets n'importe comment tu veux le
voir dans ta tête mais c'est aux accents
commence pas avec un budget informations
secrètes 1.6 milliards et et 1.6
millions c'est toujours drôle à ce qu'on
ait aucun comme bahreïn d'estibeaux coup
pas beaucoup quand on le sait pas test
1.6 million entre en compte en banque
déjà fait mais où x c'est beaucoup de
soucis beaucoup d'argent mais tout est
relatif si je devais un film de a à z
avec tout le monde sur le perron et vous
l'avez même dit un peu la première fois
que vous a surpris ses aïeux genre 50
personnes formées autour de nous et la
cameron est ce que vous attendiez à ce
défi moi non
j'étais surprise la première fois il ya
quelqu'un qui fait tout pour respecter
seul au début en fin d'année aux épaules
[Rires]
des bonbons quoi y en avait partout
cama camp parce qu'elle se trouvait en
fait mes temps vous avez reçue jarry
venu voir si vous approchez puis la non
même rythme que toi mais moi il m'a
écrit pour me poser des questions sur
comment c'était les olympiques comme la
natation était aux olympiques et tous et
puis ben moi j'ai répondu je dis souvent
c'est comme quand j'ai des entrevues
fille catherine et est consultant
sportif vous convient non mais c'est
quand même vu il ya quelques reprises
mais c'est bon là la réponse l'ongle
bien peu plus articulé c je voulais
rendre sur le plus chic comme tout le
temps tous les attentes et même après
prod quand on faisait comme quand
j'avais deux scénarios au dessus et st
george une image et la fondue chez nous
ils ont choisi j'essaye de le moins
possible de mettre comme la machine du
cinéma comme à travers une relation
qu'on bâtisse et c'était moi je pense
que ultime masque une relation qu'on
abatte ensemble c'est moi je pense nous
sommes des amis maintenant alors que je
vous connaissez pas à l'époque il
fallait un petit peu ta soeur ouais
ouais c'est ça en fait c'est andré de ma
ville la salle ariane sandrine était
aussi une consultante parce que c'est
une ex olympien une médaille ici tu peux
plus y faire avec sandrine jallet
branché avec catherine jal est oui je
sais ça me blesse à la nuance c'est être
plus cartésiens c'est à dire si la bombe
avait aussi des images
dans un relais olympique c'est les gens
qui sortent par les couloirs soit 1,8
il peut certes pas dans leur couloir qui
s'écoule à savoir mais genre c'est
vraiment le détail de mai j'ai pas mal
pour ceux qui étaient déjà besoin de
choses et inversement si nous quand même
de 2008 et moi j'en connaissais des gens
de cette année l'autre et avec des
bottes mature pour pour les nommer tv
mathieu bouchard francis gillot j'avais
des nageurs de demain de mes années de
sous mais je voulais je vous laisse
consulter des défis et puis on avait
moins peut-être dans ce temps le puits
de la natation féminine au canada ça
aussi ça a explosé le depuis le cas 2008
des messages
c'est à rio le que ça a vraiment explosé
si je pense qu'ils n'en avaient pas n'y
avait pas une médaille au canada
féminine depuis
non seulement ces partis et partie d'à
peu près à peu près ce temps là le camp
nou 1 bientôt arrêter c'est là que plus
de filles qui sont arrivés des jeunes
filles de cinq mois que j'arrête en 2008
et catherine tetteh pas encore ce leur
apporter tout a commencé comment à
devenir vraiment plus de petites équipes
nationales à partir de 2010 c'est un
premier qui se bat au québec c'est pas
vrai au québec tu étais sous le radar
commence à manger en 2007
québec on a fait ensemble je commençais
est arrivé jusqu'à la dette en 2009
annoncés jusque québec je parle de
chemise mettons t1 2009 ont des têtes
déjà crise ma sacoche n'ai jamais pensé
par substitue aux juges au québec et au
canada
howie seven qui c'est vrai qu'il atteint
par le tintamarre mac avec le gip a
répondu à la question quand je les ai
trouvés puis vous même vous savez et je
vais vous savez patente mais mozilla un
préprojet granger qui s'interroge je
vous avais pas en tête ni même quand je
commençais à jordy cta soir j'ai occulté
ce n'est pas du tout une espèce de plans
machiavéliques or thierry dejean
mais la tâche est de s'adresser bon
trouvé sa forme qu'à cela vraiment pas
du tout et puis puis black dont que ce
soit fait au fil de ces consultations là
avec toi puis survenue d'un tissu mais
là j'ai parlé avec dominique du sur la
productrice
on sait on à fait être sérieux nadia
peut-être ça se pourrait avec pour
katherine puis au début on était blond
n'était pas surplomb de stocker encore
plus et on n'a qu'à regarder toutes les
vidéos c'est parce que vous laisser des
traces en ligne des athlètes
internationaux ayons des lions des
entrevues endettée puis entre autres
petits défauts typiques de rio t comme
quand tu avais pour passer au 100 m
papillon du pilote avait comme son
entrevue qu'il était est et l'émotion
ici vraiment vraiment puis jetée comme
là je pense qu'après être touchante pu
utilement moi c'est ce qu'on recherche
en casting je pense peut-être pas tout
le monde la météo de foi est juste
soucier photogénique ces mystérieuses
lettres mais mais touchant je pense que
s'il apprend la première qualité qu'on
cherche
puis
pâques c'est là qu'on a fait quatre pour
être tout changement subit partant de ce
principe là là on s'est revus pion aux
traditionnels ont auditionné en fait on
vit auditionné ensemble puis vous êtes
vous êtes des amis dans la vie pis a
rendu ce plus facile s'est même
rapproché
c'est toi maintenant jetés en construit
jetait sur le bord de piscine d'une
compétition
non le berry toujours ce genre la coupe
3 est elle de natation puis je te
raconterai jeux racontait une histoire
vraiment niaiseuse à mes amis puis avait
juste une présence à côté qui coûtait
l'histoire je me rappelle qu'avant de
parler quand même marqué il présentait
autour de nous côte dans le fond c'était
sur internet
parce qu'elle est certaine tout déformé
échos des quatre semaines
la prochaine sortie ça lui avait caché
cette mais maintenant aux autres 15
entendu parler d'un film de notation pas
si vous que ça allait à être ce genre de
ses méthodes c'est quand même un genre
100 personnes sur le plateau et je
pensais qu'il embarquait dans une
émission à vrak tv
mais non mais avec tout le respect que
je dois à pascal c'était quand même
pourquoi on nous approchons nous pour
quelque chose qu'être un caméra ça doit
pas être si besson peut y croire jusqu'à
temps que finalement ils y viennent la
troisième audition plastique rahway que
c'était un long métrage sérieux sur la
tension est ce que est ce qu'il ya un
moment où ce qui vous est arrivé sur le
plateau vous avez fait comme ok non
c'est l'autre niveau le quai ce que je
croyais ça commence à coincer dessus
c'était le top weight peut-être parce
que j'étais pas là encore pis j'ai passé
mon expérience pendant ses démêlés
vacances avait pas nécessairement à quoi
s'attendre c'est un vaisseau n'a cédé
que tu commences à mettre vraiment toute
la dimension de lumière parce que tu es
comme la première fois qu'on en fait
c'était au parc jean drapeau le matin il
ya quand même un 2 litres 50 m si on
faisait dire tout ce qui est en soit une
chose je fais des 2 850 mètres et était
tout un budget un bureau agissements mai
isolation extérieure avec comme beaucoup
à couvrir tu contrôles pas vraiment
vraiment tendre sous le soleil faculté
s'appelait encore justin a couvert tous
i fakty c'est un peu moins
impressionnant mais effectivement ou si
familier c'était voulu c'est bien c'est
bien qu'elle est toujours dans la
logique de je voulais comme vous amener
progressivement dans cette espèce de
machine pour le bon mot mais bon on
voulait ce test est prévu qu'on commence
avec de quoi que vous avez shine et
exhale être à l'aise non seulement pour
ça mais pour aussi pour l'équipe je
voulais que les kits sont un peu
impressionné par vos stylos mais pauvre
et oui parce que c'est maintenant un peu
la natation
le tout à coup il voit vraiment dans
votre élément littéralement pété
performé au niveau où performer sopi
c'est comme pour l'équipe c'était très
stimulant aux autres d'être le put voir
seul arrêt à faire et c'est là que
c'était comme gagnant gagnant je
trouvais ce que vous avez comme gagner
le respect de l'équipe et on attend 20
vous ça vous à pau comme commencé qu'une
super active pour le jeu réputé plus
complexes et tout et tout on
recommencera pas qu'un plan séquence de
huit minutes avec une barge de dialogue
et c'est d'ailleurs si vous mangez ce
post récent métier jouer c'était nouveau
le pensez vous que ce qui vous cas
potentiels des deux genres de voir jouer
le texte l'imagination l'effet d'être
ensemble
c'est moi j'avais dit que avant dès
qu'on commence le tournage aura plus
j'avais déjà parce que je t'avais 4
j'avais tout comme le maintenant le
depuis connaît on fait le film si je
regarde toutes les émissions que
j'analyse électeurs plus passer d'un mot
justement je fais s'il faut pas tant
qu'on y pense mais ça enlève un crew
streiff un gros stress qu'on va faire
les diamètres cette semaine sur deux les
processus jusqu'à l'adresse en hindi on
faisait des comores italien dans tout ce
que je sais rien mais c'est un building
qu'ainsi on avait le temps quand même de
s'y familiariser avec etex avec
l'environnement est tout ce qui est une
première comme si c'est une première
lecture de la scène avec ce qu'on
faisait depuis la mise en place
évidemment tu es parce que bon le film
dans la soeur de mise en scène que je
préconise qu'on faisait triste et c'est
moins des coupes étaient au moins deux
plans mais les plans sont plus vraiment
mis en place des stades
le mouvement mettons mettons à rihanna
passe de l'eau alors on en profite pour
tourner la caméra lire ce qui se passe
après c'est la caméra tourne nationaux
personne qu'il ya plus d ce sont les
labors donc ce seuil avait tout le
travail de mise en place ou même vous à
l'épaule a la prétention d'avoir à m
acte hélas la politique
si je vous disais souvent mais
tranquille on le fait à six sur dix qui
me faisait un trou sur 10 chaque fois
les compris vous êtes des athlètes en
fait il fallait juste ce qu'il fallait
avec quel aplomb la performance louis
pascal mani jeter comme analogie star
intake besson s'est accroché mais mais
mais était ce sera effectivement quand
on arrivait à la prison ont été toujours
assez près pour payer ladite magie tg -
ont recherché je recherchais les heureux
accident puis avec des avec des gens qui
en sont à leur première expérience ça
arrive des fois un peu plus souvent même
puis ça fait déjà fait des très belles
choses
il ya quand même des 500 mah surpris
puisque monter le film j'avais rien vu
du tout avant il ya pour le plan où je
prends d'ouverture le plan d'ouverture
que j'avais vu mais pas monter j'ai je
souhaite le voir je veux par dessus puis
tu avais véhicules anciens dans laquelle
tu joue pis waddell s'exhaler pas la
même
cet été d'un ballon ça c'est pas la
meilleure quelques performances et moi
je pensais pas qu'il y avait autant de
scènes d'émotion tient avec des larmes
puis à mon avis ça va pas être facile de
jouer c'est celle-là de d'amener cette
émotion là surtout quand jamais faite
sur commande
mais comment vous allez je vais revoir
cette émission lieu dans la tente
puis face elle m'a dit j'en prends un
moment puis comme mais toi dans les
émotions et où je me rappelle avoir dit
j'ai dit je fais savoir un moment avec
ariane moi parce que deux secondes avant
toi qu'est dans tous les lycées
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai dit je suis arrangé sa maman la
carrière on s'est quand même reculé puis
gelé juste regarder et puis je pense à
pleurer c'est juste comme la force de
notre relation ensemble juste juste la
regarde et on dirait que je revois ce
qu'on a vécu ensemble
je revois comme ce qu'on veut ville ex
été ratissées comme cette relation là
qu'on ne peut décemment avec tout le
monde puis je sais maman alpes puis on
montrait qu on se comprenait pas ce que
la spécificité en fait ce jeu me le
demandez moi mais c'est une agite
toujours pis vous êtes bien je peux vous
mettre des mots dans la bouche mais vous
êtes réellement t alors est un peu de
votre retraite sportive
je pense que vous êtes capable de vous
profitez peut-être db c'est quoi c'est
est ce que c'est votre dernière saison
là toutes les deux ce jeu majine que
pour un premier film c'est vraiment plus
100 m que le jeu se soit quelque chose
qu'ils étaient capables de facilement de
projeter que si on nous avait demandé de
jouer par exemple un jeune rien au
danemark
[Rires]
c'est ce qu'on fait en castes et les
personnes qui ont moins d'expérience ils
vont jouer leur part un peu un décliné
de leur propre personnalité
après par exemple je n'ai parlé un peu
au coeur parce que dans l'émotion dont
on vient de le page viennent vous le
partagez le
moi ça fait un certain temps que il
finit de plus faibles mois de février
mais le coc vie depuis le bas il va
sortir et dessus mais voyez des gens qui
m'ont dit ça c'est à tournage imaginaire
quatre métiers comme à j'ai pas vu
catherine montrer que j'ai vraiment vu
un personnage secret c'est vraiment cool
puis j'espère en fait que ce que les
gens qui connaissent vont vraiment ils
vont la tête au repos elle dira t il en
entrevue je le dis souvent si c'est pas
ma vie c'est un rôle d'un personnage
mais pourrait quand tu vois le film m'a
dit vrai que des fois j'ai regardé puis
je te voyais puis d'autres fois je
regardais fiché comme wow c'est vraiment
poker jeu les ports market ailleurs
juste parce que je tiens vraiment à ça
va être un passé parce que moi je
pourrai jamais regarder cela comme je
regarde n'importe quel film c'est une
importés l'automne pourrait jamais faire
ça tu veux s'est hissé de l'analyse de
voir ce d'un autre image un gars plus je
vais la regarder ou plus on va le
regarder en général je pense que t'en
vas comme se faire à l'idée on va
découvrir plus de choses que là c'est
comme mia c'est la première fois qu'on
voyait pas vraiment vraiment dans
l'analyse
mettez vous fier de morceaux de vos
jours 30 écrans jouer puis boy sorti
comme notre famille va pouvoir aussi en
profiter tout ça c'était là ils sont au
courant de ce qu'on a fait mais sont pas
réellement au courant
maquet moi j'avais encore trop chaud
mais j'espère de la réaction des jeunes
insulter quand on travaille fort mais
ton pour faire une scène émotive ya un
an s'est jamais sais comment que ça va
être perçue finalement toutes les
réactions 10
c'est ce qu'on voulait tennessee quand
ça se pose rsa riait quand ça se pose
est la côte est proposé wanda natation
aussi que nous en comprend janvier que
parent grenoble qui atteignent aux
anguilles mechali jamais envoyé aux jeux
du québec le processus précisément
pourquoi ces îles sursis d'autant plus
important avec vous qui en kaki qui
s'apprend fois que vous voyez sur un
écran sur toile de la caméra est souvent
dans ta face est celui de toutes les
salles du film c'est vraiment le fait
c'est ce genre de projet lors de ces
journées comme cole est d'environ la
limite on est forcé d'analyser le un
personnage qui en plus dans l'histoire
du film hop a énormément de tout analyse
ou du moins éviter tout au moment où
elle vient de finir sa gare sportif puis
comme forcés à l'auto analyse un peu le
tir effectué le spectateur est un peu
d'avancé sur la réflexion du personnage
bon bref
mais pour pour aller chercher cette
intimité leur puits pour avoir
l'illusion qu'on rentre dans la tête du
personnage mais c'est ça on est vraiment
quand on est dans ta gueule tant que non
non c'est sûr que ça mais c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait une projection entre nous
ça a été bien trop intense
martin mais j'ai pas une première
médiatique
ça prend sa part le moment où tous les
coups de coude c'est vous casser un peu
quand on a tourné et ont ramené dans
l'émotion
c'est un film qui est somme toute assez
contemplatif je pense que ça peut être
bon descriptif est vraiment à deux
vitesses en fait c'est vraiment assez ce
qui me pisse a été ce qui était dur à ce
que je voudrais pas qu il mais qui était
dur au montage parce qu'il y au dessin
nous comme si quasiment son rôle et
métiers usam discrètement comme action
le 10 mai matin pourrait pour être pour
faire une comparaison un peu boiteuse le
sait un peu scènes d'action à la donne
car l'action a nommé à compter avec des
tons vraiment été emmenés chose qui
reste une ambiance sonore qui est la
conduite est vraiment mais c'est parti
il ya pas de l'action à la mairie école
en haïti n'ont comme seul mais c'est
somme toute assez
c'est ce contemplatif que c'est le mot
que je l'utilisé puis est-ce que vous
aussi c'est le genre de film parce que
vous alliez aucune des enfants
commencent à la mi avec la musique
l'ambiance ça mais est ce qu est ce que
vous pensiez que sa lettre
avais je pas est ce que vous imaginez ce
genre de film là où project artistique
mais mais beau mais pas à ce point beau
qu'on me demander comme d'écrire le film
en un mot puis moi c'était comme juste
bouclé les six sélectionnés avec
graphiques à colo colo
les internautes étaient jusqu'à en
battant maintenant quand on a tourné la
scène du relais ou quoi que ce soit et
il y avait personne dans les six
matignon on jouait le rôle mais comme
personne pour pâques la pythie juste le
voir après c'est bien tout le monde dit
on ressent vraiment l'émotion quand vrai
beau mettre en contexte c'est ce bac la
scène du relais effectivement il y avait
toutes les relayeurs les marges y avait
aussi tout le monde soit autour de la
piscine taylor les officiels tu disposes
cameron tout sommes effectivement t d
estrade vide
dix personnes parler parce que la
réaction à la fin s'écrit comme s'il n'y
avait personne le cg sont les audi
vérité comme on dit et on voit tout le
monde la presse et puis on ressent les
émotions c'était parce que c'est pas ça
se passe quand nick athlètes qu'on le
vit vraiment mais je pense que tout le
monde voit ce moment parce que j'ai
versé une larme au relais parce que moi
c'est un musée je t'aime je te parie sur
l'autre je suis vert avait plus dans
quelques podcasts ou ce que je te disais
c'est moi ce qui ce qui me rend émotif
c'est joli les tu vas sur youtube simard
jarrets des speechs émotionnel
d'athlètes laitiers genre un athlète qui
détient annonce sa retraite à la tête
qui gagne avec sa femme soit mortier de
quoi de toute cette affaire là tu dis là
c'est comme ça qui est ça me touche et
moi - une foule qui crie ça me touche
c'est une foule qui crie 6 à un run mari
de bonheur pur déjà une bonne course
mais d être content du résultat
le titille à la fameuse course de
michael en 2008
j'ai les re regarder y oppose pas l'ont
tabassé sa pop tout dans mon fils en ce
moment de l'année d'élie moi désolé
percuté juillet août c'est bon ce temps
là les gens me demandent les olympiques
puis les y être empreinte flashback tait
parce qu'en ce moment il ya un creux ce
que peut donner c'est ça c'est populisme
osmos mieux facebook
et puis là je les regardais de a à z qui
jetaient a faim il y avait encore des
frissons
comme c'est la réaction des gueules
pitié dans le film on ressent un peu
selon la nation le
moi ça c'est ce réel c'est un des
moments les plus
weir de ma relation avec le sport
mettant le 4 x 110 états unis en 2008
j'étais tout seul chez nous mais par an
puis mais s'arrêter au chalet puis moi
je pense que je travaillais à
l'université fait que j'avais peut-être
seul chez nous puis ça s'est passé
pitié je prends pas nécessairement pour
les américains je prends pas
nécessairement pour ma liste est donnée
pour mac os faire piquer l'isaca ramener
alain bernard 5
les américains ont gagné je me suis levé
si on dit 20 cl il en est capable
qu'est ce que j'allais chez les jeunes
ont envie de crier mon seul chez vous et
lisa qui ont monté des points 8 le
dernier s'il ya des gens qui connaissent
un peu la natation la sni boulot tu
remontes pau puis alain bernard avait
quand il le sent riverains plus je pense
après il gagne un premier gain de points
8 sur un an
c'est un moment tout le monde qui
connaît un peu qui a écouté la natation
tcc c'est le sait le moment j'étais avec
des amis le fort heureusement on est
tous ensemble mais c'est pas que j'étais
ou quand j'ai réagi quand je m'appelle
possible
mais l'autre fois c'est un 2012 qui en
trente ans a regardé comme sorti de chez
nous seul marseille habitait était ma
voisine
je suis parti à course nu pieds en
bobettes en ligue 1 eric schumacher
légende avec ça criait déjà de l'autre
bord de la porsche fait que j'ai avec
eux aussi un secret non non non mais le
dire puisse esquisser ce qui capote et
piste un peu ce que le film voulait
représenter c'est pour un hors jeu
c'est un peu comme un je pense la
gymnastique patinage artistique certains
sports comme ça tout le monde très dans
le temps des olympiques mais après cela
pendant tes tout le monde juste et
fiable du monde où c'est le même niveau
6 est malade mais c'est hyper niche team
usa legends jaga drop à la natation et
j'avais du monde fina ainsi l'an passé
puis pourtant plein d'affaires malades
qui sont passés cette présentation
mais ici c'est ce qui est spécial des
olympiques tu sais comme tout le monde
devient une fois aux quatre en tout
genre femme ne voulait t2 des athlètes
le dax c'est enivrant pour un athlète
après ça si tu te retrouvais le oui le
sport ça c'est capote et puis c'est pour
ça que le film si tu parlais des
contemplatifs en même temps il ya des
moments intenses il vraiment en
montagnes russes puis je pense un peu
comme ben comme la fnath est une jours
de solitude une genre de rigueur il ya
des moments mort mais en même temps il
ya des moments d'euphorie total com dont
on vient de parler c'était important de
montrer leader c'est un défi rythmique
si c'est un défi de garder les gens qu'à
engager parce que il y en a qui peuvent
être juste et melissa et nous comme où
ça brasse pélissanne contemplative sens
comme chez moi le meilleur café juste
regardé le film comme se sent vraiment
vivre ce que la personne villa nadia vi
dans le film comme ce soir ils
comprendront pas nécessairement alors
que tu es si tu passes à travers les
émotions petit comprend vraiment ce
qu'elle vite il se fait apprécier
vraiment un plus même si c'est possible
non non non mais c'est
faire ça donne un espace de réflexion et
je faisais pipi témoin par rapport à la
contemplation et on vit dans un monde où
tout va tellement vite mais steam et ont
pensé à jour les plus beaux moments de
vos villes la plupart du temps ne les
moments le marquer au fer rouge avec
mémoire lotis c'est des moments souvent
août comme arrêt type de gens
regardaient et et pourrait le genre fait
l'inventaire de vos moments qui
transformateurs
la plupart du temps il y aurions il y
aurait un effet de pause
on n'a pas arrêté on a fait une faute au
mental on a comme vécu on a digéré on
rompt le prix dit pourquoi les films
nous donner encore plus d'émotion je
tiens compte tellement d'émotions c'est
ce qu'on se rappelle pittis aussi se
lier la question de s'arrêter dans le
moment les ti cats écoute un film comme
ça j'ai l'impression qu'il faut que tu
te laisse vraiment porté par le film
faut pas que tu penses trop hein qu'est
ce qui sent qu est ce que le film qu'est
ce que fait de me toi ça c'est mon code
de l'eau jusque là ça a mené par sa
puissance je pense est bon dans tout un
matin j'avais justement cette réflexion
la chaîne orange et vienne est inouï
phone story
la dernière fois j'étais allé sept jours
mais mai puis un essai comme picasa
concentrés surtout qu'un petit continent
l'europe
tu vois ton ombre acteurs c'est un
nombre qui nagent avec toi qui met en
avant pis plus fait juste concentré sur
ce puits le géant matin comme toutes les
choses que je suis réaliste écrit
cependant à pratiquer pour une fois
parce que je n'étais pas en train de
penser à prochain et sans m'en est ou
prochaine foire qui s'en vient au genre
quand j'ai fini ou leur qui est aussi
affaire le prestige aux phoques
je suis juste à être le dû me concentrer
sur ce mouvement là puisque les séries
parce que j'étais en train de fondre
mais le qui tombe comme dans une étape
de transformation
ben il fallait que le film amène dessous
c'est
il ya effectivement belle l'eau des jeux
de steam même le son le rapport
c'est la gravité comme pas pareil aussi
longtemps il fallait comme que le film
donne sept jours de couverture le
d'immersion sensorielle et two way
effectivement la scène la musique ou
s'il va dans le plus dans ce sens là
aussi on est beaucoup dans le l'ambiant
le planant ni comme c'était rechercher
la scène dans la boucane c'est celui qui
remplace l'accord par les tests
techniques mais c'est pas juste pour
faire du symbolisme ne un peu facile
c'est parce que moi je m'appelle chez
vous ça doit arriver de temps mais moi
je faisais des rails vous immerger dans
des non-lieux ces genres drive que tu ne
manges c'était des connaissances dans
une piscine spécifier ses décors n'ont
pas de visage un peu plus je crois que
tu manges lève à 5 heures du matin pour
aller nord ri
mais nécessaire est débarrassé que ce
n'est pas juste pour le genre de
symbolisme c'était vraiment comme moi
j'ai des rêves de george north quand un
non-lieu jeunesse le bessin autre que
moi je me rappelle c'est sur montauban
pour ne pas le nommer il fautif lui
faisait des marathons d'olive puis il
faisait quand les sme en déclin mais
parce la version cd km diffuser des
semaines de 100 kg le tce 100 kg le 100
kg ha course c cole et semant des kilos
d'école ce dernier en tant qu'un
entraînement puis jetée dans un bus à
côté lui parce qu'on allait on avait une
journée mais on s'en allait au centre
ville de porto rico
puis il y avait des spasmes musculaires
il s'est endormi dans le bus ces spasmes
musculaires c'était droite gauche
chaque trou à chaque tournant tant pis
genre si quand même eu trop non
[Applaudissements]
titulaires qui pense en ce sens il de
naja respire un autre hall respirante
ces semences et c'est même peut-être un
autre point que je voulais parler par
rapport au film qu'on a checké hier il
n'a dit révoltée en salle dès maintenant
car vous allez écouter ce podcast le il
y a tout le long du film puis je pense
pascal l'expert l'expression que tu
disais c'est ils ont leur sport tatoué
sur le corps s'élançant soit ce que le
physique que vous avez un physique de
nageuse s'assimile un physique forgée
par des agents des années et des années
a passé plusieurs dizaines d'heures à
chaque semaine dans piscine puis ça
c'est vraiment une touche qui qui est
impeccable titre ims à russell je ne
peux pas être répliqués c'était vraiment
trouver tout des détails comme ceux-ci -
téléfilm canada y était présent au début
le coskas des non professionnels
autrement il fallu que je plaide pour ce
têt en voulant dire téléfilm c'est notre
investisseur majoritaire avec la sodect
et mettons deux bailleurs de fonds
principaux le thé pour les films avec
des budgets substantiels
non mais mais mais mais pitié chaque
entraînement je sais qu'un autre qui ce
passe en natation pittis un traitement
avec un acteur qui s'entraînent ips il
va c'est bien correct mais d'entrée de
jeu c'était pas l'intuition c'était
parce que je voulais faire c'était pas
de doublure je voulais vote double à sa
sortie c'est quand je trouvais ça même
pas même pas de natation juste venu de
sport en général quand on y pense c'est
plutôt rare qu'on voit des gens faire
une vraie performance physiquement comme
des maisons au début tu es chez toi tu
as les pulsations comme bastia la fin du
plan les gens sont rougis gitans ce pays
on travaille on fait un effort
pensez-y hopper de films qu'ils font
réellement à notre pomme ne peut que
très très peu
puis rennes le 13 avec moi moi le pas
restée on va qu'on va connecter avec
elle par l'effort physique ce qui est un
pari que finalement presque aucun film
notre part on avouera vous me dire aux
gens qui voient le film de misère si
c'est un bon pari mais ce mois ci et là
ils ont aimé ça c'est bon mais mais mais
il a fallu thé dansant ce pauvre tu as
peur tu es toi tu disais aussi si je
vous ai choisis
ça doit pas être un film c'est sérieux
mais même de l'autre côté du lit où les
bailleurs de fonds sont comme on
investit dans ce groupe et on pense
qu'il peut faire un bon film sans
scénario est bon pilote et que tu vas
pas prendre des acteurs pour résoudre
des genres tommy le genre 10 mois
pourquoi j'ai convaincu
non seulement c'est un risque de faire
sauter de faire jouer en octobre en plus
tu fais des scènes avec des plans super
l'on n'était pas casqué soit capable je
m'attendais pas ce qu'est ce que je vais
peut-être autant comme des actrices mais
quand même ça je pense en clic ils
feraient pas moi je pensais que j'allais
avoir ajusté m'a mise en scène un peu
plus que ce que j'ai fait ce que j'avais
que vous étiez capable type déjà vous
avez le bon casting ça c'est déjà une
bonne grosse affaire de cochon était
jusqu'à il ya des films des fois que le
problème je filme ces genres l'acteur
est mal castet ça arrive le mois
vraiment quand certains je regarde quand
j'ai jamais cru au personnage principal
oui j'ai jamais crue alors chimie où
j'ai jamais bon déjà son os avec cet
écho chez mais ensuite auquel il ya
comme justement la scène dans le bord
c'était je pense que cette page de
dialogue
puis on a décidé de le faire en
séquences dans les fautes locales et
semant des places vides alors c'est ça
c'est parce que dans mon film précédent
puis dans certaines micro métrage
l'institut que bon que j'aimais bien
plein de raisons moi j'étais vraiment
prêt tôt dans le processus a fait
regarder si les plans c'est quand ça
marche pas pour vrai on voit comme s'il
faut deux caméras tout entier pour
découvrir autrement faire plus de mon
table sur ceux reçus ces six mois je
pensais que peut-être devoir faire plus
donc être encore plus souple moins au
niveau de la mise en scène finalement
non
faire la mise en scène coup comme des
actrices mme peut-être toutefois ces
informations le mais est ce qui te
compter le nombre de plants in hope
autant il y en a tous marre alors que 2
5 par exemple où la british heart lane
en bon français la durée moyenne de
chaque plan monte en flèche si les
scènes justement où on avait de gameiro
il ya deux semaines dans le film tv vous
en rappelez il ya 200 nous séparant de
lui promet un pouce web comme le soleil
s'était filmé ébloui par ton talent mais
ce serait factice et sign up et une
méthodologie que j'avais un peu fait
dans certains me trouvent dans ces
scènes là doivent pas à être au-dessus
de la moyenne cinéma général non non non
non ça franchement que ce match entre
autres chats avec un petit peu d'études
et sincère parce que c'est parce que mes
tantes et d'ailleurs maintenant que je
fais un jargon de cinéma t30 podcasts et
du copilote il nous dira tout chanter
c'est bon parce qu'on est comme on dit
ouvrir vers la caméra dans ce temps là
pour justifier une coupe faudrait soit
fille drastiquement d'échangés de valeur
de plans ou de cegid et sicce pas mettre
la caméra derrière mais pourquoi
peut-être parce qu'on a un peu ouverte
et peut-être qu'on voit chez pas moins
une deux jolies demoiselles marché
devant nous au pire était peut-être
qu'on a envie de voir ce mais peu
importe mais c'est sion rien qui motive
mais coupe dit qu on est dans un stade
st jean qui ouvra vers la caméra
moi j'ai tendance à me dire ben je
couperai pas encore une fois faut que
les actrices à part mais mais
mais voilà c'est fait qu'il y ait quand
même ce minimalisme l'ap le tout à coup
d'un montage devient expressif c'est pas
juste comme hey je mens je coupe pour
dynamiser ont été dynamisées moi ça veut
rien dire des choses aussi on a le bon
rythme en plan de couple c'est ensemble
qu'on a la bonne répartie pour vrai
coupé de liens de respect refus bon
d'accord c'est un peu tout seul mais
mais il ya eu également de le faire
c'est l'ultime ans et c'est la vraie
avancée comme je moi je pense que les
gens vont voir le film
c'est mon souhait quand même voir le
film vont pas faire at ccse comme le
juger comme turquie my way genre avec
des noms acteurs c'est que c'est des
actifs c'est-à-dire l'actrice vous avez
vous performez n'entend parler de la
scène du relais puis si je me souviens
bien c'est un plein l'a63 plein stade
aussi trop longs plans séquences toutes
les débuts exactement c'est tout tout le
corps d'or yari ce bar la piscine le
relais commence de les deux premiers
relayeurs c'est combien de temps tout et
pour tout juste avant que sa cote après
après l'entrevue finale 100 mettons ces
trois plaintes qui sait quelle main sur
un bon 12 questions lancées minutes
l'entrevue à la fin là c'est la fin d'un
long plein 20 minutes que quatre touches
au mur dit que la caméra change sur un
plan séquence calendrier qui fait son
100 m crawl l'école étant le dernier
descendant du raid qui dans l'histoire
il ya le fait pour vrai iphone fac
triviaux le fun c'était ça j'avais fait
exprès de maître sandrine classeur
l'arrière
sandrine était couloir à côté c'est la
grande bretagne fait qu'à la fin
à quel point que sandrine j'ai dû l'être
assez peu de chance reste du monde qui
est encore une brawn avant deux mois une
autre fois puisque le capteur deux fois
ça arrive et ça un petit peu au site est
composé des plans parce qu'en plus on
fait des plans télé pacitti est plutôt
dans le film pour regarder comme la les
caméras officielles de votre relais mais
ça nous il va lutter les fêtes il ya va
lui faire des passes steve laplante de
coleridge télé on est excité puis c'est
vrai il y avait certaines figures
antilles puis serrant correct ses doigts
la ferme était comme il était tellement
intense que la russie est tous vraiment
avant le canada ça marche comme plus les
joyaux la russie fokine ça marche plus
parce qu'ils ont invité deux bannis
c'est tout tu dis que tu parles de les
buts dans le film annie dit je vais
aller en australie pour les koalas
aujourd'hui dix fois le l'oeil comme le
coach local
ça joue mais la boxe école c'est
clairement d'école que tu dit voyons
donc que city dans un film c'est l'école
de grosses octobre mais en même temps
[Musique]
c'est que c'est tout
tout c'est que le sport d'élite à une
logique interne que le film ne s'était
pas été dedans tu le tuyau pacs aide
mais en même temps moi je pense que
c'est important
l'idée d'ailleurs notre choix c'est
vraiment de très de l'incursion
sociologique le tt tt dans l'envers du
décor d'une égalité olympiques mais
l'olympique à la limite plutôt un peu
c'est un peu métaphorique tout un peuple
aimanté ultime mans c'est comme tête
avec des gens qui ont des vouent leur
vie à faire sur jusque dans les détails
et essai comme moi je pense que le
cinéma de fiction peut avoir une valeur
documentaire aussi tu es un bon film de
fiction qui t'amène je sais pas où tu
mets ton geste pour la cité de dieu j'en
ai invité t dans les favelas la violence
au brésil bon c'est un film de fiction
mais t'es tu sors d'un film de fiction
qui tout comme wow si j'étais comme
alors sociologique ou ethnographique
s'exciter maintenant exactement une
bonne fiction nous amène à ce mois
c'était vraiment gâché c'est exactement
ce que je pense qu'il serait jamais été
c'est jamais pu en fait on n'a quasiment
jamais vu même un documentaire juste
mettons toutes les petits détails
auxquels on a accès j'en parlais ya moi
c'est ça qui me fait me fascine avec se
fait menacer les détails des petites
affaires qui ont causé les gens sont
rasés c'est juste je donnerais anciens
il sera vraiment les acheteurs exemple
hocine si nadia qui porte tout le temps
pas si bretelles de maillots ces jours
ci sait même pas ce n'est pas quelque
chose qu'on se compenser plus appréciés
de la scène où est ce que justement du
relais où est-ce que vous sortez du
couloir puis là tu demandes à mark hurd
de mettre tes bretelles le tda m
d'hébreu test des petits détails que tu
vois jamais rien qui change par la bbc
j'ai trouvé cette oraison quand tu dis
que la fission une valeur documentaire
est parfois aussi intéressant c'est que
quand tu sous-estiment pas le spectateur
moyen
en fait ça peut avoir cette valeur le
camp ces mots j'ai hâte de voir la
réaction du and kim et grand public le
titre d'avoir un accès ou 6 et
privilégient aussi réaliste de ckoi
l'intention de haut niveau au dessus
j'ai vraiment l'impression que tout le
monde j'ai vu des films de sports mon
défi marica natation le tianyu québec le
titre est un cadeau mais mais de le voir
pour répression que c'est la première
fois que moment fort c'est sûr pour vrai
il savait pas qu'il y avait jamais vus
sur mes livres se rendent compte qu'ils
ont jamais fait cette saison n'est
sanglots
d'ailleurs notre vote prenait pas de 4 à
5 ces coupes mais on est tout et vous
êtes encore dangereux métier on est trop
ancien
sinon je saurai si vous n'avez pas non
mais s'inquiète c'est quand même une
bonne fiction pourra vendre
c'était alors le sociologique logique
c'était pas le bon bout parce que je
prends une société la nation mais peu
importe
mais ces quatre tu m'avais dit ça c'est
au scénario t parce que c'était aux dit
et écrit les dialogues le titre de ce
troc rails depuis le lac tapis de six
autres il y avait comme prendre
plusieurs termes 13 natation ultra niche
qui était éthique était scénarisé qui
était écrit piste mais la réponse à la
question l'heure c'est le comment qui
est intelligent trop crues météo rien
mais moi c'est que kevin web best way
c'est bon mais moi en fait c'est que je
me rends compte que moins de spectateurs
je m'en fiche des fois de savoir où
petit je me dis si les personnages et
comprennent entre eux puis que moi
finalement jeté un peu une genre de thé
comme une mouche lointain ticket que
quelqu'un qui gravitent autour de jean
luck qui écoutent ils expliqueront paul
ils s'arrêteront pas opposé à istres
hawk ride c'est le nombre de vols
employé en bon français que tout le
monde
exact mais moi j'étais confiant je pense
que bon vous allez certains des hommes
qui vous échappe mais les personnages et
comprenant entre eux quittés on décèle
énormément par le non verbal puis si les
personnages se comprennent entre eux tu
es quand même avec leurs tee ça pour moi
c'est un téléroman c'est vraiment le
gros problème noté c'est comme s'ils
vont vraiment faire une phrase qui trie
explique le thé même qui recontextualise
quasiment la patente le 10 comme si ton
coach david hiler nadia ci dessus est
arrivée quatrième à ton 100 m papillon
parce que tu es nanana nicole personnes
parlent d'eux mêmes ces personnes
parlent comme cela moi j'écris pas
demain mais mais voilà c'est que moi je
fais confiance qui a plein de films des
fois des faits mais qui dit j'ai pas mes
tantes et avec des scientifiques mais si
les scientifiques iggy qui parle de
science l'ultra 10 puis moi je comprends
rien c'est honnêtement possible pourtant
je pose est important de comprendre ces
risques comprennent que tu comprends la
vérité émotionnelle qui véhiculent en
jeu toujours qu'ils sont dangereux
si l'enjeu il va aux russes le problème
mais sinon jolicoeur qui faisait que
regarder le film à quel point mes temps
ça vous ramène le cpie à quel point vous
trouviez se réalise
non répond à votre vie à votre vie pürro
vous avez par exemple ouzou compétition
de plus haut niveau tu es à quel point
mettons vous trouvez que les faits mais
fidèle à ce que parce que vous avez
vicat l'exquis partie natation
totalement même or faut qu'il faut que
les gens comprennent aussi que dans la
façon dont on devine compétition la
façon dont mes temps j'ai vécu les jeux
olympiques c'est pas de cette façon le
mais n'empêche que tout le
l'aspect et on se prépare pour le relais
on va manger les émotions qu'ont
nécessité d affaires que oui on a des
gimmicks ut importe le niveau auquel on
est et on est déjà big c va aussi leur
relation en énergie comment je réagis à
sa retraite si ces sols dit comprendre
exactement pour ce qui reste un deuil
pour ça la personne qui part c'est un
deuil
cc c'est vraiment eu un gros chapitre le
ton n'est que quand on me l'a demandé ça
en entrevue tantôt changer quand on m'a
demandé est ce que ça te préparer de
faire ce film le comme ce n'est pas la
retraite au travers le film est ce que
ça te préparer à la vraie retraite des
garde fous king comment son nom mais
honnêtement je suis quand je pense pas
qu'il rien qui va pouvoir me préparer à
ces sentiments-là dans le sens où ça a
été toute ma vie a été toute notre vie
je veux dire si ces émotions là je
voulais vivre coûte que coûte puis je
pense pas que rien qui va pouvoir
diminuer vraiment cette peine là parce
que ça va être quelque chose que je vais
arrêter quote ok c'est moitié maintenant
le dans tout ce qui était natation j'ai
vu aucune fausse note le titre de mon
expérience à moi j'en vois la bombe et
non mais j'en mets ton la dossiste
couloir mais ça arrive même de vos
articles sur une fille qui vraiment
fucking lanta comme des autres des fois
y'a t'il des fois unie au pays.le
on fait même et puis d'ailleurs vent
c'est un mythe qui était parce que c'est
mon film georges tron qui est parfait
c'est ça ça arrive tu es moi après ça
c'est drôle ça des cinq mois qu'ils
n'avaient pas vu personnellement fait
mitigé on le finance en février moi je
regarde pas me mêler aux autres
personnes avec qui ce qui a travaillé
sur le film quitter chaque personne dans
son domaine voyez des petites que chez
autant la maquilleuse thèmes que tu fais
tous les détails à 3 5 millions dé
taipei à la 5e doit peut-être un peu
manqué de temps qu'il ya peut-être de la
sphère que finalement c'est après que tu
as fait à gérer peut-être juste et jay
la scène d'une autre façon a peut-être
que cette ligne de dialogue de nairobi
je trouve que le si si une autocritique
que je dis c'est bien mais bon je trouve
que le plan plus symbolique qu'il aurait
peut-être avoir la [ __ ] un peu plus
d'os là-dessus peu de temps maintenu un
plan magnifique comment inverser la
remontée de l'eau tout ce monde
extérieur mais genre en le revoyant cinq
mois plus tard j'étais comme ça que tu
laisses des petits de symbolisme libre à
l'interprétation
j'ai trouvé que ça devenait vraiment une
dimension films ses pieds pas déranger
mais mais mais c'est sûr mais en même
temps cette espèce de petit côté un peu
masochiste de voir les défauts je pense
que dans l'absolu c'est très bon très
parce que telle étude montrait toujours
faire mieux que c'est une déformation de
réalisme une chose qui est que
spécialité le yankee qui n'a jamais vous
allez pic le type solide à l'état pur
allons d'ailleurs à l'ats par exemple ce
qui nous sauve à l'idée c'est qu'à
londres 2012
c'est sur des dates des civils qui met
d'accord métier c'est que ce cela se
sait exactement une décision puis c'est
même une conversation qui ont eu des
métiers le budget n'était pas fini
encore une fois comme visée 1.6 millions
liés si j'ai sur mon compte en banque
mais il faut que cela est audacieux
quand ça pour faire rené un film de
rased costumes et des masques
non mais plein plein d'affaires plein
défi tout juste l'infographie on
pourrait la prendre pour acquis métier
juste tout les bonbons japonais que vous
mangez le site des faux bond
c'est lassant s'est dit vraiment bon
mais c'est difficile il faut aux
emballages c'est tout l'infographie
lineker ben j'en ai fait imprimer il y
avait une équipe lorraine richard
parsons en train de faire des packagings
pour venir mais pop la même puce et
packaging partir une compagnie de
bonbons non mais
les cinq compagnies de bourbon au japon
la compagnie de bonbons japonais ici à a
marché pour eux mais c'est quelque chose
qui ait capoté tu sais que aussi les
jeux olympiques c'est je pense que ça
paraît pas dans le film mais on va quand
même et est un yoyo peau d'âne on l'a
fait le seul à nous convoitons tattoo le
voyez je vois quand tu tombes glace au
début oui mais on le voit dans la scène
de nu aussi je pense ouais par l'été je
dirais des fois on essaie d'être un peu
surpris de ne pas trop mettez lice avec
d'intimité c'est les scènes que tu
improvise pour zillisheim que même si
c'est contre actuellement la tige aux
heures où ça c'est la cie la limite si
on signe sur ce c'est ce qu'on s'entend
à faire finalement c'est drôle parce que
on est on est finalement doivent être
moins que ce que vous avez comme signé
pour deux ans de façon c'est finalement
n'était même plus pudique que peut-être
on aurait pu
puis ses ruches content je content parce
que tu penses pas que c'est ce qui va
rester mais tu dois peumans n est hélas
and after party mais ton jeu tallinn
maison marie pia et plus dévergondé
qu'ariane de la 106 ton personnage les
actions qui apprend bon valverde pour ce
métier à apprendre la drogue récréative
bon ça tu appartiens métier je ne pense
pas que c'est comme c'est pas trop table
mais donc ceux de savais que j'avais
assumer que quand il se ramasse l
hôpital et aldo ce même temps j'ai voulu
balancer parce que tu es ya un
personnage t elle offre un autre doute
le dos dit non les anglos t sont quand
même un peu plus stricte et la fille de
17 ans et comme témoin je boirai pas
l'autre
chaque été au mois je pense que j'ai
quand même pas fait un portrait de jean
tout le fracking mon nom je vous le dis
ce bâtiment non mais je sais mais c'est
plausible que mes dons avec lala le
pourcentage de personnes t-il le plus
mettons ça se disent pas non plus une
fabrication de base mais aussi persuadé
jamais jeux olympiques mais je suis
persuadé que le père senti le plus c'est
que non mais c'est sûr mais c'est
important pour moi parce que tu es je
voudrais utilement je suis en train de
prétendre que le comportement de nadia
marik heures c'est le comportement de
tout les olympiens sur leurs épaules je
pense que c'est clair qu'ils font des
choix aussi des personnages puisque pour
moi c'est important aussi que ce soit
dit si les personnages principal mais
c'est pas non plus des héroïnes moi je
mettrais cette nuance le tgv zone adiol
il ya des boutiques est un peu beach
débogueur
ce métier qui me connaissent que
j'espère c'est sam était bien plus est
plus renfrognée plus taciturne était mal
dans sa peau d'un personnage qui m'a
dans ta dans sa peau je pense qu'elle
est la salle mais la grosse différence
je pense en a deux et quatre mois si je
te trompes et ta vie pour rose bonbon à
toute heure du jour mais comme tu es pas
mal dans ta peau nadia et limal dans sam
je pense que la grosse différence y en a
d'autres mais la grosse différence c'est
sa dimension un personnage qui peau bien
dans ce qu'elle vit quand c'est fait
mais fauga sorte c'est ça devient
quasiment sa recherche d'identité
ça c'est une fuite le ton c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un bon film je
m'attendais pas à ce que ce soit aussi
bon je m'attends à ce souffle sur ce
soit bon non mais non mais pas sûr que
oui oui ok je sors que même toi tu
disais ça serait comme ceux qui captent
embarqué en projet c'est fait fake mais
mais comme de fait mais ne sait pas
alors que ces films ont été sélectionnés
à cannes pic qui rit ce soit bon
ces foules mais moins ses hobbies bon ça
à partie les goûts divergent bon bon
expliquez moi je suis fier parce qu'en
fait c'est ce que tisse sur le plan la
demande de places soit la personne ou
soit c'est un film qui crissement comme
grit
il ya des films que sont le fonds de az
le petit fini pire était peut-être 1 706
mehdi karoubi le pari c'est que ça sera
pas ce genre de film le sait je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui vont être un peu
aliéné par le film qui comprendront
peut-être pas nécessairement ou qui vont
être un peu comme déroutée pitt est
dérouté va être personnel plus
négativement bon t il falloir se quand
il hors du monde il faut faire crise
enfin
une comédie romantique avec une bonne
famille hagemann à la seule j'essayais
de mettre les spectateurs et c'est
vraiment à se mettre dans la sélection
tout qui commémorera qu'il n'entraîne ma
victoire est donc un montage de requis
quatre genres plus de jour qui parce que
comme tout c'est aussi parce que non je
fais partie n'ont pas survécu
c'est faux c'est de la bombe mais si
j'oserais et export acquis 4 parce que
la boxe est comme bien représentants
mais non même dans tout ça parce que je
sais pas mais je pense même pas qu'il
faut que tu écoutes natif de fly parce
que la nation est bien représentée je
pense que ça va servir le film exemple
dans un film hautement inspiré d'un
processus
ça ressemble utilement vraiment un peu
mais si un film puis surtout je sais que
tu eu des bémols parce que tu connais
bien le jazz mais whiplash les moules à
l'acheteur peut certes gaulois qui la
musique moi je te mets à côte mais parce
que moi mettons dans weeds parce que moi
j'étais comme il ya une carence de
représenter les athlètes tels que j'en
ai vus tels que je les véhicules tels
que quitter mettons dans we plage à
donner un exemple qu'on mettait legault
il veut y est comme écrin qui domine le
tennis et je termine premier tour mais
permanence fait une blonde puis là il
laisse sa blonde parce qu'il dit georges
mais un plan dans le cheminement du
roaming
puis l'affairé des émeutes et honest ce
soit par des gens voyant un choriste
puis pour un spectateur moyen belle
gosse sociopathe c'est une décision
extrêmement mais moi je comme l'ex
attaquant - comme je pas en train de
dire que j'aurais fait ce mais poussés à
l'extrême quand tu vis il ya quoi
tellement intense c'est plausible gens
jetés comme pour moi c'est un des
meilleurs films qui représentait cette
espèce de folie la 2 duo retriever
perfectionniste extrêmement dit ce soit
la natation ou autre chose il ya des
fois des métiers tu peux être de même le
tt pauvreté c'est comme c'est ce que je
fais puis je veux le faire bien et
pillent
tout qu'ils aillent peau à moi devenir
meilleur qui plus est là dedans d'un
tête-à-tête et quartier de ta vie mais
semaine c'est un danger parce que le
site est italienne tout plein de genre
de gens autour de toi des fois ta
famille des fois des amis que tu vois
plus des fois des relations que tu
l'aimés les périls hcp jeune quand j'ai
commencé à être bonnes clés vraiment
vraiment dans le sport est tellement
m'obliger à aller voir mes amis sociale
qui quand j'avais justement le 15 en
béton qui avait absolument pas que le
sport prennent trop de place dans ma vie
avait déjà une vie normale ici pas qu'il
appelle à y aller par mes amis c'est 5,5
mais c'est vrai pts et 10 canadien vie
d'enfant nadir el allam à l'aise avec
les faits qu'est ce qui tourne autour
d'elle tout le temps qu'ils d'enfants à
ça et égocentrique égoïste de com pour
suivre son rêve mais qui est dans le
fond ça ça lapointe n'avait pas tous
âges aussi à ce que tout le monde
réagisse ces décisions pourraient elles
aussi mais le même métier c'est vrai tu
aimais tant pis je le parle avec le
plancher bon petit même mot car j'ai
commencé étudiants en musique le
justement je faisais juste le pitti
mettons j'avais une blonde à aux cgpi
était chez nous mais je me mettais un
album de jazz puis je l'écoutais plus
l'album de l'oreille qu'elle est triste
mais c'est un équilibre souvent que la
maturité te permet une certaine forme de
maturité de permet d'équilibrer ce sera
ta vie tu peux vivre une passion extrême
mais aussi mais c'est un magnifique rend
compte qu'il ya d'autres choses à
ministériel micro de philippe moretti
mais je pas pourquoi qui avait ressenti
qu'il fallait que nous sommes et ça
m'avait marqué
c'est l'fun mais si je serai là ta vie
tu vas passer à côté de bain des enfants
ce qu'est ce qui est vrai pour la
musique puisque est vrai pour ce qui est
vrai pour savoir quels patients que
c'est juste la seule chose qui existe
il ya trop de choses dans le monde envie
pourquoi
pour une fois que c'est sur une seule et
même base pour être un champion pour ce
quils plh ma part l'été au delà du fait
que oui peut-être un peu gros butin puis
tout le match mais tu es comme telle et
telle une scène dans les plages telles
llc le le maillon son propre vraiment
trop extrême à la faillite et qui dit
jean claude job c'est les mots les plus
dangereux le thé comme quand quelqu'un
fait quelque chose de plus médiocre un
peu ordinaire puisqu'il ya ces côtes du
good job sa dignité c'est bon pareil
c'est lui comme non vendre seul ça
détruit des legends le faut que les gens
soient state grid si je vais pas dire
good job se mérite paul joe pesci comme
c'est encore une fois ça peut sonner
sociopathe mais est ce que je comprends
d'une façon vraiment bizarroïde cette
logique l'oeuvre une logique de gens qui
trouvent qu'un kit vie des athlètes d'un
certain niveau petit moi mais moi que le
cinéma je ma gentille ont fini par
devenir extrêmes moi j'ai vraiment j'ai
pensé beaucoup dernièrement a justement
cette question là à savoir qui est ce
que est ce que pour les 0,0001 % du
monde qui vont finir comme michael
phelps est ce que ça vaut la peine de ça
c'est encore plus de 0 à 0 à la casse
mais mais dont est ce que ça vaut la
peine de qu'il y avait beaucoup de monde
qui se mettent hors ligne pour jamais
arrivé mais c'est apprendre la
définition cela va peut-être la
performance des cairotes
j'espérais mais là je parle non plus en
tant que société est ce qu'on devrait
et justement tir avant le discours de
dire hey fait autre chose vive et autre
chose tu veux vraiment réaliser quelque
chose il faut que l'effort pour défaut
aux petits maîtres du temps une tout
état peut choisir sinon on fait tout à
moitié puis on n'arrivera pas au succès
puis je pense que nous on est toutes été
dans un sport fait qu'on a eu tout l'été
à un moment donné on a tout mis pour le
succès où que ce soit pacte et je pense
que si on veut vraiment quelque chose on
n'a pas le choix mais j'ai l'impression
je démens puis celle hautement alex j'ai
l'impression que pour ceux qui qui sont
pas utiles vraiment le maillot faire du
monde
j'ai l'impression que tout le reste de
diversifier les activités des passions
des trucs ça va permettre d'amener une
certaine perspective
admettons que tout ce que tu fais dans
vie c'est la natation juste tu vois
personne te pas vraiment d'amis te pas
vraiment vie sociale consentent jeu sur
ce picto une contre-performance ac s'est
cassé le lotisseur des qualifiés j'ai
beaucoup d'athlètes qui ont été quand
même et on quand on en parle est et qui
ont peu d'études se soit puis justement
quand ce là l'espoir vos papiers ou
qu'en l'espace de vie vendée souriez
epic est l'exemple le plus frappant au
dessus c'est que je te ment prend les
meilleurs athlètes non la barre athlète
de tous les temps michael phelps après
sa carrière est déprimé au point de
vouloir mourir si c'est la preuve que ti
focus et sur une seule et même affaire
cellphone pendant que tu fais confiance
à votre bail en ligue 1 que c'est plus
le
ça s'apprend d'autres sources de
valorisation de bonheur des costumes et
même un peu la paix le film tisse et
nadia justement tu sais c'est comme si
tu es sexy la personne que jamais été
notamment
c'est un peu comme ça que je voulais
construire le scénario le personnage
maîtrise pas décemment tutoie tout quand
même été une prune wonderkid thé dansant
était explosive petit dit toi tu étais
là personnage manière dans le film si tu
parles d'un d'une jeune qui est comme
juste vraiment talentueuse puis qui est
un peu rappelé la vie pitié qui fait des
jeux olympiques puis je viens de gagner
une médaille péter comme l a vu à la
peau véhicule même genre de sacrifices
que moi j'ai vécu tir puis fait qu'en ce
sens je pense que nadia et pourrait
peut-être plus proche de sandrine je
peux me permettre de t'en sortiras sera
là comme toutefois king sa réaction
l'action 2006
les clashs aller exactement mais en fait
c'est moche donc je voulais que nadir ça
soit exactement sous tu sais la fille
que genre pour favori père ans puis le
succès qu'elle connaît
c'est le sacrifice n'est pas égale d'une
année à l'autre le talent est pas égales
le le tombeau l'année papa de musique
tout est parcours sont différents
bon c'est sûr qu'ils les ors mettons les
au 3/4 que tu as passé à bassin versus
les ors que penny oleksiak aux passants
le bassin pour le même temps paul même
résultat mais le résultat que vous avez
eue ensemble c'est comme qu il s y colle
esm applaudissaient je parlais pas quand
elle parce que c'est une question de
parler quand même capable de dire qu'ils
étaient jeudi elle a commencé sa
carrière puis peut-être un futur est
exclue mais je dis a commencé donc à
l'avait pas encore vécu des chèques ale
pas encore si tu donnes à saipan traîner
encore dix ans je dois a commencé son
succès
designed de sueur des victoires des
chèques de remise en question de tout
seul mais dont vous avez dit allez vécu
un peu après par exemple je vais pas on
le vit tout à un moment donné à des
périodes différentes notre vie puis non
exactement exactement fact yves le mouël
dans l'idée c'était un personnage que
justement à le tellement mis le reste de
sa vie sur pause parce que si havre
atteindre le green est c'est peut-être
pas la personne qui le si naturellement
que se le dise la personne chamakh il
faut qu'elle fasse le tour de vraiment
bien aimé dit quand tu fais tout
vraiment bientôt plus assez de place
pour dorian dervite e place pour avoir
un peu de folie de places pour tout ça
que ça c'est encore pire pour nadia de
ces faux qui a quitté parce que le puits
sur tout et là là certes elle dit même
littéralement une réplique du film qui
quitta ses qualités a dit j'ai une
relation abusive manque la natation
c'est peut-être que lochte en train de
quitter une relation 25 immo qui m'a
apporté beaucoup plus de malheurs que de
bonheur quand il ya du bonheur il
devrait boire et on a parlé avec
microsoft dans tout ça mais sont rares
ces moments de gloire quand on a une
déception c'est clair personne d'autre
qui veulent suivre comme on dit mais tu
es tu dessines ou mamie c'est un
licenciement ni d artois mal à accepter
moi je me rappelle mais on était allé
c'est le low light le de ma carrière de
natation j'avais j'ai apprécié tout le
temps les championnats de printemps il
assuré car a dit jamais un canadien
ceux qui parlent après ça n'allait
jamais y ont tout le temps humain tout a
été un peu moins important considérant
que les chats mais le divorce était les
sélections aux affaires loti avec la
deuxième partie on a tout le temps un
petit peu plus tough lutter pour gare de
rester motivé quand tu as tout le monde
qui part en vacances qu'ils retournent
chez eux
puis m moi je vous rappelle ramener les
charbonnages les sélections était finie
je vois un peu plus tard qu'il ya un
épilogue j'avais vraiment été à face sur
mon entraînement
j'avais été je me pointais métier je
tenais pas l'effort jeter tout commence
en plus j'ai jusque là qui claquait
nucléaire logement dal est arrivé aux
championnats canadiens d'été
puis j'ai fait je faisais encore des 212
dans ce temps là puis j'ai fait déjà je
n'avais pu le dire rien à personne mais
j'ai fait ce genre de 14 l'année tirée
d'un rien
je faisais deux sens et que la grosse
mare d'activistes à bloc je ne sais pas
gratter tu plonges sorti de l'eau peut
jusqu'à l'arrivée ce ballet du bar du
sur les estrades siaci nekim du mort
fait ph postaux des questions puis je
suis parti parce que je ne tiens plus et
41 condition que j'avais déjà vu cette
conversation lorsqu'il faisait ph cet
été ça marchera pas je te vois en entrée
en matière il me l'avait dit au fond de
moi je savais mais la chine restera le
dit a cité des chiffres et des lettres
volées pour venir jusqu'à victorieux
pour nager contre les meilleurs nageurs
au pays
pitté de la maggia d'euros l'an passé
y a personne d'autre que toi à blanc
mais pour ce poste est juste le
p la paire a fort apprécié comme arrêtée
pendant 6 mois pourra revenir avec une
meilleure étoiles d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'a demandé qu'on arrête aussi que
voici zone ces deux semaines normalement
aussi français que je finissais je
pensais que c'était fini le jeu menti
c'est fini je fais quand macheda type
mode est une astuce georges pleut à 16
puisque un moment donné tu es juste pu
bien le faire une petite pause et
question quand la taille de vos pots ci
s'attend pas d'aléa piscine pour
t'entraîner c'est déjà des gens
influents de la borne 6 4 après cette
pause m
je suis revenu après les jeux olympiques
je l'avais cette médaille est le reflet
dans ma tête j'étais comme qu'aimer
c'est quoi mon rythme que j'avais juste
l'impression depuis avoir des rêves de
nos j'ai juste parce que je t'aime
dangereuse puis parce que les gens ils
s'attendaient à ce que je mange
puis c'est juste mon mental a été puni
décembre ont fait que mes performances
s'il était plus le nom + tickets puis on
dirait que les gens involontairement
mais à cause que tu as déjà gagné
ils s'attendent à ce que tu gagnes tout
ce que tu fais j'avais juste
l'impression dé de se voir heureux de me
décevoir moi maintenant je suis bien là
dedans puis non il fallait que je me
retire de sais pas ce que je serais pas
encore un financement si je l'avais pas
fait je pensais que tu as arrêté puis
après dans cinq six motos fabriquées
dans le reste est une vraie semaine à
l'université
tant que les causes des carabins à
l'université de montréal est venu voir
en asie de quoi tu le fais tu viens pas
avec nous juste pour le plaisir était
pas de pas de compétition rien t'es
juste au début qui est ça a pris
longtemps lesaffre ils ont terrebonne et
puis si j'avais un peu en dedans alors
mettons là qu'au début juillet mais je
manquais des pratiques si je le faisais
juste parce qu'on dirait qu'il me
restait soir fait c'est puisqu'elle se
retrouve vraiment c'est à noël
c'était à sienne c'est noël là en fait
charles à québec parce que coiffant fin
2010 et 2018 2019 en fait
puis mon ancien coach marc en hockey
hockey je vois que je vois souvent que
je vais à québec en fait si je montre un
vécu qui lui il m'a toujours vraiment
brasse et émotionnellement je pense que
mais n empêche qu ai je pense que j
avais besoin d'être ce moment là de ma
vie
la maman d'anne images esprit d'antenne
mapera côté puis me dis-je en un acte
indiqué steve et le shabbat et j'ai déjà
vécu ce que j'avais avec est fait ici
tant kalfon en fait le nom pauvres sinon
on arrête le site est en train de faire
n'importe quoi puis m'a tellement
grossier je pense j'ai pleuré le
pentagone a rejeté comme qu'est ce que
je fais il me brosse les pyjamas brossé
à l'intérieur émotionnellement et toupie
à partir de ce moment-là partir de
janvier on est passé du tibia
je me suis mis à à mesure qu'ils mais
c'est vraiment pas trouvé un objectif
j'aimerais trouver une raison de ces
drôles télé l'espi de motivation de
quotités c'est un cliché du chum de
sport mais à stx est vrai que comme
quand le coach arrive à qui bon goût la
porte pour nous le cdij ans et plus un
mais c'est vraiment beau à tout le monde
qu'il ait agi de la même façon des
interventions bon je suis je suis je
pense que mon co sexuelle claude mérite
pas la même histoire avec le même bagage
de bagages et différence qu'à ce moment
là c'est ce que j'avais de besoin une
pie
je sais même pas s'il sait que fait
cette influence eu lieu dans ma carrière
écoute ça y est c'est dit mais ça c'est
une autre affaire aussi c'est tout c'est
la force de mon corps je savoir quoi
dire quand dira pas qu'il dise oui
c'était clair depuis j'en ai vu j'en ai
vécu deux mondes qui criait après ces
athlètes également le modeleur soit bien
là
- tu m'aimes de musique free pour le
reste de sa fortune vie aux séquences et
sûr capable de voir la différence est
que lui peut prendre la job à la joe bar
mc je vois mon truc non des mamans
notables de la ville sic et il m'avait
dit ça car chaîne en creux avant que
j'arrête ça m'aurait cru encore mais
gentil c'est ce qui est parti
l'été venu cliffs a glacé objectif tokyo
2020 en fait je suis revenue
et c'est quand même long processus et
qu'entend arrêté ex nombre de mois dans
le sport d'élite
puis j'étais confiante et signé cette
hypothèse c'est la reconstruire ta
confiance et toupie mai-mai chef c'est
la chose la plus longue et reconstruira
matin à sion les six mêmes en fait en
septembre sept ans comme septembre
dernier le champion du cameroun
la gazelle temps j'ai recommencé
justement avec eux avec claude à
montréal ont fait tuer c'est ça pis j'ai
eu il ya eu un déclic s'est fait je me
suis vraiment entraîné fort puis pauvres
et j'y croyais vraiment je croyais
vraiment pesé sur un pipi ma leçon je
peux te dire de quoi que je t'ai jamais
dit on est dans le scoop c'est un
mélange
coucou c'est nous et nos colonnes la
question qui tue le tournage c'était au
mois d'août qui est d'à peu près votre
hors saison à toutes les multis puis moi
je pensais pas qu on avait prévu le on
avait prévu on a vécu lors de tournages
en fonction que c'était les physios toi
tu es enfant tu te fais appel à moi je
pense que oui que vous deux vous allez
faire les championnats dans pong dans
une version gt plus tôt donc nous ça
nous donne plus dur en haïti pour faire
le tournage au complet tabarnak estimé
dans ce sens dans le sens où si je pense
pas que je suis vraiment pas ça pour te
sous-estimé non mais vous estimez
s'était pas mais c'est comme si ta
saison tu es pauvre est et comme mettons
un an et demi donc un an et demi avant
les juges et les jurés taxé comme étant
à un an des essais pour tokyo donc à six
mois entre des pannes en dessous bref
partie du parti de loin le liban qui ici
un pylône pour me protéger moi même je
disais même où joe bouffe je me rappelle
quand fait justement donc là c'était les
championnats voyons les essais la
qualification de ces rentes et quelques
jeux puis le tonnage et ont 200 m libre
1 x nombre de temps je pense dur flash
ball pour ceux qui connaissent la syrie
savent qu'est ce que ça vaut puis le jeu
me rappelle j'ai comme écrit à tous mes
amis nord jusqu'à qualifier et personne
ne savait trop si c'était pas c'est que
nous y ait fallu t il fallu après ça
qu'on change tout nos dates de tournage
participer des qualifiés à une équipe
plus haute
finalement qu'est ce qu'on pensait en
vendrait ces crissements cool pour toi
tu es jeune tu auras dit est vraiment
content
c'est bon un droit qui est parti en tant
que chargé tic lorient il a fallu qu'on
tourne c'est pour ça qu'on a tourné
quelques jours avant les pandas c'est la
seule façon d'arriver tournée avant fête
du travail ça va poser d'autres
problèmes peuvent recommencer votre
saison d'année d'après quitté la saison
olympique
on peut dire que c'est quand même déjà
qu'on savait qu'on allait à tokyo donc
on allait me prendre quelques euros de
votre saison hippique en tout cas chaque
été nous leur site et qu'elle vous
pendant j'étais content pour toi mais
j'étais comme vraiment beaucoup
encore une fois je reviens en fait on
fait aimer celle venue le lendemain en
tournée ben oui il fallait c'était la
seule et unique façon qu'on allaite ya
pas de calais le film le lendemain
départ n'a pas du tout perdu la voix
même jour
c'est en fait offert folco parce que tu
es j'ai tellement essaie de rendre sa
relaxe pour vous donner tellement
l'illusion que c'était pas un gros
projet m'est témoin pour moi maintenant
c'est un immense progrès substantiels
c'est comme ça que ça marche ses filets
je me rappelle titre me diop tu mets ton
que je reste une coupe deux jours plus
tard l'aller au pérou le savez pas
encore donné la date
sherbrooke a très bien ne l'avait pas la
main du petit bleu si je reviens on peut
se tourner sur mon dos de la productrice
aucune faute en étant vrai coup dur à la
semaine agitée comme neige les plus cool
plus relax l'acheter comme l'info juste
tourner le fameux lâche entre autres
effets cette expérience-là d'acting ce
quelque chose qui vous crime peut-être
que tant qu'ils vivent actuellement dans
ma vie je jouais à faire ça mais mettons
je mettrai pas toutes mes cartes là
dedans mais c'est un rush d'adrénaline
puis une expérience que ça me
dérangerait pas de refaire sexisme et on
m'approche m'approche pics et des ce que
j'ai considéré j'ai considéré parce que
c'était vraiment une expérience qui est
on revit vrai je pense juste et c'est
être il en haïti trois critères un
territoire mais j'ai vraiment aimé ça
mais j'ai grandi et je l'en avant moi
minded 2 est-ce que je serai capable ce
que j'ai déjà
je suis vraiment un monde où un moment
j'ai dit que ça me gêne je suis métisse
mail
après des accents pizzas puis en tout
cas je me suis fait de trop pour ben je
me suis fait parler des places au ce qui
donne des cours d'acting après après le
visionnement pour continuer d'en faire
d'autres
c'est tellement d'efforts pilon devenir
bon à quelque chose le moindre hic chip
ou d'abord béton origines angers mais
j'ai montré que je me dise plus petits
pour être bon à quelque chose tous
dévoués pendant longtemps
ok il faut choisir de plus cela m'est
impossible
il est temps que quelqu'un que jamais en
danger de sa vie non j'ai pas mal moins
bon qu'il est mais c'est ce qu'on disait
nécessairement meilleur travail d'acteur
c'est vrai il était comme ceux qui
s'opposent à une blague mais non
vraiment alors alors moi pour vous
remettons le dis parce que on parle
beaucoup de ce jeu un peu sonné comme
simone en cdd propre flore voilà que
c'est un peu là dessus le maire mais
mais tellement de monde dans le milieu
nous et et atebank les acteurs ben moi
c'est mon focus et beaucoup le jeu c'est
que les gens paraissent au mieux deux
skippers ce qu'ils peuvent mais on parle
de direction d'acteur je trouve que
c'est une mauvaise l'appellation si je
vous dis rivier pourtant servi comment
ce que je sais c'est comme diriger c'est
quelque chose d'une hauteur et
autoritaire dans le choix du manque que
kiki si mal à ma méthodologie tg c'est
de juste créer un environnement où vous
n'êtes pas seuls consultez vous
alors finalement ça a l'air con à dire
mais c'est juste ailleurs la production
je vais parler peut-être continuité
puisque comme si toi tu et à toi tu les
écoutes au fait tu l'as pas fait depuis
le début d'audience mais c'est tout à un
petit coup de jus d'un cheveu ça rendait
le glas de la continuité le stif ou rêve
s'est fourré le conseil parce que si les
cheveux sont à l'arrêt devant le rsa au
montage ça peut poser problème en bref
mettez moi georges faisait manger des
bonbons
je fais des prêts de pauvres côté parce
que si je vous parle trop de continuité
c'est peut-être que toi c'est comme si
tu vas être en train de dire tailing
mais tu fais comme étant pris dans ta
tête parce que quand même et le latex
d'avant j'ai peut-être est-ce que c'est
là que j'ai pris mon verre ou est-ce que
c'est gentiment j'ai pris mon verre
après typicité pas incarner parce que tu
es dans ta tête en train d'être un peu
le crown qui roule à penser à des
affaires de cinéma qui sont sur son ordi
prennent de là les coryphées servent
aussi à ceux du haka pas d'être vraiment
incarné mais n'ayant les réflexes le
terrain de parler mémoire musculaire de
natation le mais il ya de la mémoire
musculaire d'acting le sérieusement je
suis aussi là mais moi aussi les lire à
prendre ces lignes de dialogues si c'est
bon bref tu accueilles moi j'ai fait
exprès de vous rendre ce come le plus
invisible possible mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que ça pour était
temps que vous arriveriez sur un autre
site avec une autre méthode de l'egypte
ça threat of pour vous des jeux pas
encore fait mais l'entraidé france mais
c'est comme pour moi c'est la recette du
succès avec des gens qui ont peut-être
un peu moins d'expérience et juste
vous êtes à lens si vous êtes à l'aise
la grosse partie d'un diaby fait le pcf
comme chiffre n'est pas consciente de
l'incarner sydney 14 note le plus comme
ceux avec les acteurs professionnels il
ya des gens qu'ils prennent mieux que
d'autres je veux donner un exemple de
faux tatouages et rose marie peyrot puis
anthony terriens sont pas de très bon
comédien anthony le hilton acteurs plus
il sait pas se contrôler mario se marier
alors un naturel pas possible mais je
pense qu'anthony d'un peu plus technique
50e ni moins la maison qui fait un plan
séquence ch'ti de 8 minutes a constaté
les loges je devrais dire aïe telle
réplique le
voilà plus d'un mois mais genre ça c'est
cinq minutes d'antenne clôturait cette
instance lui anthony giacobazzi dire
vraiment des trucs spécifique genre
comme une guerre comme ceux - soit plus
un malin plaisir de medicine hat qui
était quand même ils atterrissaient
rosemary voix dessus c'était d'autres
sortes de notes une autre façon de faire
je pense que moi ma job en tant que
metteur en scène
le team massi de vous lire tout séduire
les comédiens comme un coach
on fait tout mais tout est dans tout
métier le bon le vrai bon coach le il va
pas parler parer à toutes ces athlètes
elle je pense que le vrai bon gars là
encore il parle pas parer à toutes les
attentes
mais si tu les fais une fois dans les
marchés - marchica cgt rappelant qu on a
fait quatre ans que je parle de sperme
que je donne à appeler de km d'istanbul
le cauchemar je suis pour aller la
police a finalement j'ai pris une des
premières prises vis tu avais même
oublié une communauté le fait vraiment
beaucoup de gens je pense que celle de
miss et quand on avait plus de pain avec
une pomme en avait acheté genre parce
qu'il croque dans une course b à la fin
j'en avais plus de pommes tacleur auprès
nippone creux qui planait comme pis pour
cacher ces gens finalement c'est à la
turquie était un peu tiqué lignes de
dialogues qui ont oublié que finalement
le fils à jo celle qui est tellement qui
est tellement d'apparence apparaît comme
une scène crissement pas compliqué c'est
une idée plutôt fixé quatre raisons pour
ajouter deux fois en équipe la séquence
de relais avec des apports mais 19
points 5 sur l'espère
mais c'est maintenant méthode tellement
raison c'est hyper mystérieux com
qu'est-ce qui atterrit sur ses pieds dit
je vais donner un autre exemple son
canton le film était là samedi soir ils
n'ont pas vu allez vous allez voir mais
peut-être que d'exciter bon exemple mais
c'est dans la scène c'est plus
dévergondé donc tu l'as and after party
c'est en général nos journées on ne
finit toujours à l'heure même des fois
d'avant c'était comme pauvres et puis
même au niveau budget on est et heitz a
bien été vingt jours de tournage aussi
pour faire tout les films n'ont pas
beaucoup non selon les standards de la
prod events et plus mais il ya une
journée qui on savait qu'ils étaient
ambitieuses le jeu comme la note est
entré à l'école de foot marche pour
qu'on attendait alors c'était toute la
journée où on faisait la star party qui
en plus est de 1,5 et des expressions
pour vous parce qu'il y avait ces dix
ans de l'intimité dont on avait tant par
les petits puissent agir la fac était
plutôt genre y aller yolo puis pas en
parler parce qu'il faut en parler mais
plutôt en parle plus c'est stressant
comme ça devient la fin mais sa courte
parenthèse cette scène là parce que
c'est déjà dans le milieu la natation
c'était comme ya eu ce genre de rumeurs
qui circulaient j'ai entendu way pour
contre la personne qui met sa part
infime de pour une chasse
quant à veauche avait gagné avec le
coach c'est tout de toutes les rumeurs
c'est surtout qu'en plus c'est si le
mettais adressons le moi en fait samo
same of sam a brassé puis on a changé
même langue de marketing plus et je
pense qu'on avait un synopsis outils ont
parlé il ya un synopsis qui est circule
un peu au début le court j'étais on
parle un peu plus ces deux-là de la tête
des rappelé pour vrai on a vraiment
changé
ça parle plus des des questionnements de
la retraite sportive la cnra tu es
vraiment comme selon lui trois secondes
mais je pense que c'est la sphère qui
c'est comme quand tu lis joyon de fruits
ce que les gens pensent que la fille a
gagné mais je pense que toi aussi ton
cheminement tout moment actualité moins
que dessus ce qui distribuait des
milliers cordon ou alain picq la mérite
à une histoire dit il y avait ma faim
avec ce jusqu'à jeudi leurs réflexions
l'écriture de ce test et de maturer
aussi d'en faire un film qu'il faut que
ce vraiment là dessus c'est peut-être
pas aussi intéressant que ça marche un
film sur l'amitié et sos j'essaie de
d'en parler aussi de plus en plus tu es
je pense que bonds à 10 ans quitte
marie-pierre reste m'est épicé ici c'est
un grosse partie du film et sortait sur
comment le nez l'autre vivent t comment
disait le deuil mais le deuil d'un hors
bord et le deuil de l'hôte et
marie-pierre halal est un personnage qui
est un peu appeler à vis de ce mécanisme
en lucidité pour que pour qu'elle arrive
qui a 10 k 10 à la fin de la façon de
makabi tc comme je t'ai pas juste à
sidekick un peu comme boniche le tester
comme jeter a exigé d'eux même par les
armes étaient amanatidis bon est arrêté
par là bas bones urbatys parce qu'à la
crise m'a remarqué qu'à la faisait
je trouve que cette ligne leur le type
les gens qui ont le film vont l'avoir
dans son contexte mais je trouve qui est
vraiment important en picardie vraiment
beaucoup sur les tons pâles lucidité que
marie-pierre par rapport à douter il ya
plein d'exemples de sutil la manie le
l'entraîneur chef qui dit équipe mais
vraiment de sport le personnage anadipp
quitter c'est ta dernière course
normalement petit toi tu vis des prises
en otage finalement tu voulais pas
nécessairement visiteurs de passage où
il peut décemment vivre cette espèce de
spotlight le sud-ouest moment-là du film
mon bref c'est le choix de mise en scène
de rester sur voudrait à la fin du stade
il lâche pas un plan où il a fini juste
sur ta face c'est un plan qui est
délibérément finisse ou deux parce que
tu es toi tu es comme la vie tu es tu
essayes de même un petit mot sur le
temps tenté lot suspect important qu'on
comprenne que tu es crissement lui si tu
sais ton personnage est vraiment lucide
puis après c'était ma la scène avec le
coach quand sa pile été marqués ressort
puis à l'arrêt depuis a fait comme
hawkish catch que le lion leur
conversation qu'il faut qu'il aille type
le titre tourne midi au mont d'or c'est
peut-être pas le temps d'en n'a cessé dé
détails de périphérie mais qui sont
importantes c'est ça notre longue
histoire courte la dimension amitié au
pris le relais moi j'aime lady chimie
j'aime les films de où il ya eu oui
c'est qu'au les saucisses et nadia ces
deux protagonistes de passage éponyme
mais ultimement ce qui est quand même la
dimension d'un terreau relation est
forte
c'est ce témoin quand je me rappelle de
mes années de nos joueurs c'est mes amis
aussi c'est vraiment sûr c'est la gagne
c'est la communauté une orientation le
coach me met vraiment les gens innocents
hyperventilation sur borde basse
c'est ce qui est beau il fallait pour
faire un film de sport pour moi c'était
l'un des plus anglais plus riches à
aborder pour tout ça pour dire que oui
effectivement c'est parce que c'est un
phénomène délibérément moi quand j'ai su
le qui avait comme des rumeurs dans le
monde la natation le site à faire leur
effet et pour l attaque et moins on
s'était tous la scène qui vous stresse
elle plus ou peu plus qu'une autre toit
cinq groupes
scénario c'est ça allait plus loin
qu'est ce qu'on voit et à la nation a
signé pour plus que les miniers détail
métier non mais pauvre et c'est ici que
ça s'ajuste marché et mais là on a fait
comme dit pas entendre cette partie là
où je m'en allais avec mon histoire à la
barre ce pour quoi on parle même de la
scène d'après parti c'est que la seule
journée on filme sans ressort comme des
puits en overtime kanté de nuit avec
tout le monde sur le pont lors de plus
pour les uns c'est bon mais de fait la
production le lac le thé ont fini
mettons les plans principaux de la scène
mais au moment où on aurait dû finir la
journée on n'avait pas les fans de la
cen sad on n'avait pas le ton petit le
côté de toi qui comme bonjour la scène
d'un meeting
pis le côté si toi tu es le choc on est
en overtime si on n'a pas la fin de la
scène
c'est petit c'est comme si les fans
complexe donc ça marche tant pis si vous
faites pas ce que je faisais à 10,4 chez
je pense que comme le fallait juste que
ça que j'essaye de peau comme projeté
aux grandes cités je trouve un trou d'un
martèlement jeter comme momo tic nerveux
ces genres de france benjamin fall
estime que l'on est en overtime
et en plus nous on avait comme des
ambitions de grandeur avec la transition
parce qu'après une fierté c'est comme
700 morts dans une scène de sous l'eau
qui comme onirique cela premier plan
sous l'eau un peu plus stylisée bon bref
elle a développé la directrice de la
photographie
on avait comme plein d'idées funky de
comme la transition étaient armés de la
lumière à travers l'aquarium saveur que
l'art est partout mais en plus on doit
mettre comme genre un filtre aquatique
devant la caméra pour faire une
transition avec de l'eau plus large que
même en étant humble times steph le
stéphanie cela développer autant de
volta melons fera pas tout seul le
chauffeur je comprends je comprends le
vois comme à log au doigt et à l'oeil
d'or en parallèle genre l'équipe comme
remplie en aquarium ayant arrêté à la
voulais faire ça ça c'est comme ça c'est
tout prend sacrément mais pour revenir à
vous telus com il fallait que ça marche
fort d'un coup puis vous avez tellement
aimé le titre je pense que j'ai toujours
dit c'est la scène fou comme tu
embrasses le doubs comme tu prend le
lead de bon je pense que je pense je
suis juste dit arif fait bouffer tout
cru le si je pense que même un seul
conseil ça a été gentil le bouffe tout
cru
là le démontre posséder en effet le kop
en effet sur tech finalement c'est le
genre de l'attique a rejeté comme hier
fort qui y est ce parce que nous
aujourd'hui dans un monde parallèle où
normalement on aurait peut-être eu deux
journées pour faire tout ce qu'on a fait
de cette journée lot quitté mettons
qu'on a eu deux heures et demie pour les
faces et deux plans le on n'avait pas
fait le meilleur selon les organismes
tels shôjo rego google dirigera comme
donner quoi tellement frénétiquement
incroyable puis pourquoi être toujours
comme ça parce que tu sûr sur un
éboulement lundi je dirais que c'est
mais quand ça marche
genre vaudreuil plan comme sur le but de
franzen qui en plus vous stressez vous
personnellement qu'il est dit et c'est
qu'ils sont des vrais athlètes qui ont
compris ils ont compris la pression
opinions personnelles mais moi je
pensais pas que ça allait être comme ça
c'est la scène de ton s'enflamme dans le
fond le plan de la course
moi j'étais arrivé elisha devient ici
non mais c'est pas que des journées ton
âge tu es aussi investi
fini fatigué non mais ça c'est ça ça
t'es vu quand même toi même autres
prévenus parce que toi tu es part active
dans la vie aussi le thé nageuse à temps
plein voyons design intérieur à temps
plein et en plus je pense tu avais dit
qu on peut fois le sort c'est quand même
un tournage note est entré à la lady le
faut qu'on se parle ariane a avancé le
nombre d'or cccc la charge mentale
mental et un épuisement
je sais qui c'est arrivé sur le plateau
cette journée là au final un pic puis 4
était déjà là en fait les deux et il a
pu leur est fait ailleurs 12 ans ont
fait toute la jeune fille de nuit
prochaine de nuit toute la journée puis
là moi j'étais je mange peu après c'est
moi je fais ton grave encore pour lala
km pas fonctionne quand même fonctionner
par jallet passive il y avait donc des
filles moi je fais tout ce la mâchoire
le pichon qui est ce que je suis brûlé
les jardins de martonne shinobi je me
couche pas ce que je suis défoncé depuis
le toit t'arriver sur le derby avec ton
maillot n'a été lancée 9% les sens je
t'avais trouver plus stressés danse elle
est aidée comme il n'y a plus rien qui
fonctionne genre ça marchait pas on est
à dix pendant je veux dire c'est que moi
c'est que si je suis un peu dans quelque
chose que je peux contrôler je serais
pas si stressée tas de béton mais tant
qu'on y est un défi humain c'est moi je
suis activement pâtissent à trouver la
solution pas que le stress finalement il
y est dit quand même dans un tiroir loin
dans ton cerveau parce que tu es dans
l'action sauf que le c'était pour la
petite histoire courte c'est que c'était
noté rich est un monsieur plan l'ayez
fait c'est la caméra de kinect la caméra
avec un caisson qui est trop pour lobant
rivier sur des poulies loïc est mieux
tiré oui oui c'est toute la peur c'est
top
maintenant ce n'est pas un gros quinn
qui était à particules alors quand le 3
mai mais non mais bouygues et aux
hippies non testé à dire on l'avait
quand même mettons tito jackson lui il y
aurait eu un week-end qui suit le même
boîtier soit qui aurait pu même aller
sur mars ou alors de l'eau qui rêvait
d'un gâteau je t'entends faut être
créatif et les budgets comme un oui
c'est en partie parce que je te
mangerais chat le est fait sur un
panneau noir de rigueur les poulies ça
finit par marcher c'est jusqu'à 90 à
quel point effectivement je suis précise
parce que le leur mettons et je vois le
temps qui passe qui le temps c'est
laboris il a donc l majuscule au mas
jusque-là d'henri que tu recherches de
l'otan c'est tout aussi des mots t'es
vraiment quand on a plus tu peux faire
plus
quand on a pu cissé s'est fait hors de
l'eau lapenty c'est vraiment intense
puis qui loge or je vois le ça marchait
pas aux gens ça a marché smi avec toi
mais toi je pense que quand on dort
rapide qu'on ait commencé des tests avec
cap qu'elle concrétise sa marché
américain sorti qu'en mai ont été
précédées jambes ces deux cadres et en
eau chaude ce ça a pris peut-être même
façon mais c'est que moi quand schiele
l'appui châssis puis là je vois jean
leman gosses parce que c'est pas le cas
face à nogent 100 m papillon le jour
j'ai quand même bien que je te parle
quand même atteinte je sais comme un
enjeu nature est béraud deux libéral
mans rien que je peux faire
sauf genre stressé je vois le temps qui
s'écoule
j'ai aussi que se tient en plus est je
pense la journée d'après qu'on avait eu
un overtime vite et on peut on ne pas le
genre de budget que ça peut jouer sur
une base régulière puis puis en plus
c'est un vrai effort physique
non je pense 100 m papillon à cette
vitesse et autres ne manquent pas un
athlète des traces en 10 portées 100%
c'est pour toutes ces raisons pour
toutes ces raisons je t'ai ultra
stressée
puis encore une fois c'est gentil les
astres aligner un peu la magie du cinéma
j'imagine mais ça comme marché d'une
telle témoin j'avais mon petit moniteur
- oui cela fait un peu il paraît que
c'est faux ce qui fait que si j'avais
mon petit moniteur portatif t c'est
vraiment mieux pour moi que c'est ce
qu'on appelle un bon jargon une bille
jeté une beach et le moniteur qui bouge
pas pitt et moi j'étais assis dessus il
ya des gens de l'équipe qui ont besoin
de voir les autres sont là mettez moi
j'aime ce que je vois il faut que je
voie ce qui est filmé mais juge un
proche d'action bon bref puis je me
rappelle le genre je faisais plus que
les 100 pots le faisait mille poules
genre tu manges et le plus les gens
regardent mais une part le plus acheté
comme juste je faisais genre détour des
piscines thermales l'acheter comme je
sais pas si ça marche petit notamment
comme on le cas ni jeu ça marche et ça
marche et ça marche et oui on la copie
enfin playback on regarde ça marche
comment que c'est bon de finir la
journée même au début tu avais pensé à
même sous louer ça apporte le marché
mais au final tu sais ce que ça donne
c'est celle là c'est juste la plus
grande proximité avec une rhétorique que
tu peux avoir avec ce qu'est ce qui est
un défi c'est que le covering visuel de
la notation à ce niveau là l'un pays est
vraiment beau c'est vrai que les veaux
quand tu regardes en natation les années
que la notation la grande canne et roth
et à la cale en eau la capsule au tc
teyran beauty on savait qu'on pouvait
pas il fallait pas dispo l'esthétique du
film c'est parce qu'on voulait faire ce
métier c'est qu'on a on se fait des
grosses bottines c'est vraiment bien
couverts le très léger
joe thloloe bon c'est différent c'est
plus utiliser le bouscat bruges en tête
avec cech et la course c'est eux les
oyats raté finalement c'est un film qui
suit la subjectivité nadia donc avec les
mêmes joueurs canadiens puis même les
ailleurs dit même au niveau soit morte
c'est comme quand tu es dans l'eau quand
erreurs de l'autre il ya un gros travail
aussi de ces une subjectivité de pour
que le spectateur il voit pas hypo loin
en train d'observer seuil est proche en
train de vivre
le bressan que je veux qu'on sorte un
petit film qu'on parle maintenant de
comment vous vous entrevoyez mettant la
prochaine année pis après la prochaine
année mettant votre vie d'athlète puis
dans les autres stades cette écoute un
peu patente je dire on espère juste que
quelque chose va avoir lieu
c'est parce que le tampon faux pas comme
si tokyo 2020-2021 people même soleil
aucune certitude sur moi je préfère
vraiment le savoir dans la minute qui
est plutôt que le savoir le puits mais
j'ai fini ma carrière
alors ok je préférerais tumeur est
entraînée comme ça les lieux puis de
ferdinand encore une fois deux semaines
avant les essais pas déçu moi mais tant
qu ayant annulé jeu le jeu sec avec du
recul je me dis ce terme mais enfin
montré que je leur ai dit pourquoi pas
prendre une chance d'atteindre à diana
minutes que peut-être ça et l'iut et je
sais pas avec moi ça va plus déçus de le
savoir autant d'avancé mais là avec
toutes les circonstances qu'on ait vécu
c'était la meilleure celle ci mais
mettons
j'aime mieux m'entraîner c'est un hippie
me dire à tes prendre la chance puis
genre y croire le japon présentation
plus comme le fabuleux c'est parce
qu'ils me dire genre d'homme fort de
soutien à nu lépine meeting avec tout ça
pas de fatwa commentaire
il plaisait le plus en quelque sorte oui
mais thil et l'exclusion
le plus que tu peux dans les sports sont
toujours en fuite et mettons en ce
moment le fonds kleiner lambiel ayant
comme un espèce d'aspect y appelle cela
la bode miller
ouais mais divisée en deux semaines mais
c'est quelqu'un qui a des jeunes eux
mêmes y perdre des athlètes banon mais
ce soit mais là je suis jarre dans les
communautés mettant en australie a perdu
plein mandat des dpi et percute pas où
ils ont perdu des membres parce que le
monde c'est une porte ouverte à une
immigration histoires comme celui il
faut jouer les pk je pense à ceux nés
avec la côte d'ivoire
ils se pointent la journée de son relais
manque de goût bizarre c'est un des plus
gros enjeu majeur
j'ai l'impression que les olympiques
c'est tellement gros que ils vont être
capables si je veux pas me mettre de
faux espoirs ou quoi que ce soit mais
tient la lecture que j'aimais tant de ce
qui se passe avec la nba planète celle
c'est vraiment sont capables de
contrôler à fond les entrées et sorties
avec du testing dont ils disent toutes
les achète arrive de le semaine avant
non mais c'est en fait un évident mais
c'est celle ultra précieux le droit
parce que ça puisse être faite le sait
enfin village les jets village mais
c'est parce que même si tu arrives à
deux semaines ça serait rien m'a
vraiment étonnant que les personnes qui
[Musique]
disaient non mais tu t'entraînes tu
votes tu vas avec une distanciation
sociale tu vas t'entraîner mais ils
l'ont fait pour la nba celozzi - c'est
moins d'athlètes mais il ya quand même
quand les smashes tarissement du monde
où toutes les reporter les médias à
eternit de m
il ya plusieurs délits en accès à
guichet fermé it et aucun spectateur rit
avec ça c'est sûr que c'est sûr que les
spectateurs pour répondre et ça c'est
sûr si ça arrive ya aucune chance à la
côte en ce moment si ça mais c'est le
même principe qu'en ce moment je te ment
encore une fois pour reprendre l'exemple
philosophe faut qu'il va avoir des
pertes le titre c'est sûr que ce soit
pas une expérience olympique comme
toutes les autres
ça c'est sûr et certain et on le sait
déjà le tir c'est sûr ne sera pas une
expérience olympique
les fans en 2021 dans n'importe quel art
n importe quel bâtisse
c'est vraiment très peu probable qu'ils
avaient des spectateurs nous le parti
fait ce j'imagine que c'est à prendre en
considération
mais j'ai vraiment le feeling qui vont
être capables de faire quelque chose
disparaît des sondages qu'apparemment
comme 60 % des japonais ne veulent pas
payer pour d'autres et attend il y était
très tôt les descenderies le beaucoup
les gens autour parce qu'on attend au
japon en 8e puis je voulais vraiment
savoir un petit come c'est quoi leur
perception c'est des jeux olympiques au
japon pis à la base la population ni
pacte c'est comme même dans le contexte
de tokyo 2020 et le
pas de quoi vite tout va bien la leur il
ya une grosse part des japonais qui
voulaient pas les jeux je pense que
c'est de plus en plus comme ça le beau
rêve liste l'olympisme
tout est beau la distribuer toutes les
gt le rêve olympique pour l'athlète je
ne ressens rien à voir avec la magouille
l'industrie parce que si c'est vraiment
parce que c'est l'ampleur de ce que ça
représente
mais effectivement c'est de moins en
moins était juste jean luc brassard
l'oeil cerclé telus en est un qui était
très verbal très articulé dessus sur un
peu les travers de l'olympisme tel qu'on
le connaît pas six stations
quand chrysler en mitraillette les
arguments le site durera près seul
d'être complètement le genre liste des
toiles dans les yeux de voir les yeux
limpide être émerveillé comme on le dit
quand on regarde écoles et j'étais tout
ce qui va compter
tu as fait des championnats du monde où
je passe était de mon métier dans madame
annie petit tu dis on construit des murs
pour qu'on voie les bidonvilles et était
comme tout pour qu'on est ici derrière
les bidons et limane mois qui précède
c'est comme si on dit ici je vois des
images après son installation comme sur
andreu
c'est tellement d'argent tant
d'investissements après soul et les
installations sont comme ceux après le
stade à rio ouais je pense que c'est
plus dur pour le co2 de masquer tout ce
temps et en heure où les nouvelles
circulent ce sont les voi t la fondation
de l'olympisme et est basé sur le rail
le l'oreille vissée frites l'interdît
c'est à dire la fifa le seuil haut c'est
un peu représentés comme questions comme
la mafieuse mois avec là dedans et comme
[Musique]
la confection de plus au niveau de la
salle dans la
j'ai juste la natation ming lee qui
sortit lequel commencer l'année dernière
ce qui comme les pros de natation est ce
qu'il est les équipes qui font des ddd
compétition contre l'eau puis que
l'argent derrière ce laffineur a menacé
au début en disant si vous participez à
la lnh roaming ligue pouvait plus
participer aux compétitions de la finale
et ce même si d'école sans plus y a
plein d'argent qui ont fait déjà rage
non en fait henri aller chier je
pourrais peut-être faire de l'argent
compte professionnel à connotation plus
pour venir au champion du monde quatre
qu'on parle de tout ça m'était oui je le
dis souvent le métier vous aurez la
spaque orientation t city fera marche
ensuite quelques titres un peu de
commande id tu fais un peu de tout avec
des bourses mettant canada march ensuite
une petite tape dans le dos 0 0 c'est
vous pas sur l'or le tout porté pour
exposer son compte en passant par
m'étais juste c'est ça la cpo
c'est une gloire qui quand il vit elle
est là elle est démesuré était un pays
au complet qui est derrière qui appâtent
métis pays là il va passer à autre chose
quand les jeux france taxi s appuie la
kids c'est celle des records québécois
leur accord avec toi qui seront sur un
échec c'est que 5,6 et le job à temps
plein si je pourrais la météo pour
ouvrir le genre note institut sportive
au canada
la natation on à couvrir le relais la
médaille de bronze lounge en 1512 et un
4s convient vraiment été honnêtement les
traditions les pétards exemple d'un
contrat par exemple avec karine ok puis
dakar je signe un contrat avec a rien eu
j'estime le contrat avec natation canada
que je reçois pas d'argent avec eux
parce que je mange pense pidoux genre
payant nailloux je sais qu'elle a
présenté les détails spécifiques à ces
enveloppes doutez pas cette garantie
vraiment pas
que tu puisse continuer à pratiquer ton
sport avec un avec le gel était le
confort et ce n'est pas le confort le
jeu c'est juste qu'il faut pour pouvoir
le faire à temps plein les jambes au
canada et on se demande après soutien
pourquoi ça va moins bien dessus c'est
ici que c'est plus dur de garder les
athlètes longtemps dans le circuit parce
que tu es tu as besoin de faire une job
en 268 nice que les gens payent pour les
camps d'entraînement du pays pour les
gens ce qu'ils avaient à faire
khakikat on était rendus sur son podcast
sans restriction les dix sites et un
site était vraiment c'est un bon argent
tu vois arriver à zéro afin de ta
carrière tu envoies sa cécité c'était
vraiment comme bonjean rapacité
crissement bon dans l'expectative et
dont la méthode par la mettais mes temps
une peignée alexa qui revient quatre
médailles olympiques le convoquer des
séances
le tout le monde l'a vu m mais pas moyen
au m2 mais ça c'est l'ultime exception
moi j'ai eu une bonne carrière natation
c'est moi j'ai quand même été chahuté
jeudi j'ai eu des bourses et tous mes
jeux concerne que spawn territoire
finale nationaux tout le temps c'est des
équipes et en salle quand même pu
travailler pour payer ma natation mais
je suis consciente que les moyens à 100%
c'est vraiment drôle
à quel point juste mettons l'idée de
s'entraîner pour nager le plus
rapidement possible c'est ça la peau
dutil 10 et pratique le matin c'est
vraiment si bernard du bâton 50 la tête
1-1 10e plus rapide au 50 libre le tout
et comme ta carte et sait-on hachimi
possible tout à fait tomber ce thème de
genre 10 centièmes et et genre le
commandant des centièmes sa excède comme
la raison le titre c'était pour l'argent
c'est pas parce que si tu sais c'est
vraiment injuste parce que c'était juste
et dans la vie cela chauvat plus amusant
qu'il faudra quand même créé qui
souhaitent ouais c'est ce métier comme
c'est vrai la mode des salaires etc qui
n'ont pas appliqué et et c'est ce que je
suis c'est un même toit
ça fait c'est l'école de la vie
mettez mettons tu mens je vais en italie
non mais t'es tu manges à 50 crawl en 30
secondes quand même un pas pire marge de
leur genre n 4 technologies dans les
études mes tantes et au cégep en
sciences et à québec c'est simple et
c'est jamais tant qu'homme il faut 30 33
en médecine le ton tant que méthode des
trente et un défaut qu'une bombe noire y
voit les gens du pays dans les domaines
que ce soit et que c'était le paquet en
sciences nature mais tu peux rien faire
parce que ça fasse un peu tout mon avis
au stc fo comprend les seconds que ça
prend à faire 1,50 pour après se mettre
des personnes sur un piédestal et giget
plus cool si le second le genre la
différence indique en effet 22 4 puis
22,9 est énorme mais en même temps
laisser sommet sera surtout une médaille
de bronze pile médaille d'or
les gens se rappellent pas de la
personnalité dans une finale olympique
dans un 50 libre il y en as tu vraiment
un meilleur que les autres processus
c'est le centième lattès et l'épreuve
les cinq ans grâce est l'épreuve la
moins stable que c'est tout le temps
quelqu'un d'aussi qu'il n'y a pas eu le
bus un bond de 5 ans que les boues six
ou la natation
yapo mais moi je pense pas je pense pas
vraiment en plus de plus pauvres non de
plus pauvres n'ont pas vu leurs jolies
filles qui comme la 50e genre les autres
sont le pilote
mettons plus important 9,58 c'était ce
matin mais en bourgogne est tout le
temps qu'il a perdu 1,5 en 2010 est un
genre 2012 ouais ouais je sais sur le
stream il mais ouais avant qu'on leur
jeu qu'on finisse le tour mais pas le
tour de table mais je vais finir ce que
la laque à camper répondu oui toi rien
n'est pas proche quelques atouts mais je
réalise que peut pas tout et je trouve
qu'ils aiment faisait mois ci un peu de
jeu juste avoir comme lui parce que moi
j'avais comme j'avais peur de finir ma
carrière mais j'avais hâte de passer à
autre chose
à 26 ans et je travaille je marquerai
professionnels d'enclencher jambes est
encore chez mes parents et que j'avais
tellement hottes et finir ce chapitre le
de mouvante et un parent puis de faire
plus que 35 heures adultes de me
concentrer d'enfants à 100% à une
affaire plutôt qu est quand même passé à
disais que tu es sexy tous les partis de
se faire former en natation temps vidé
de bonnes surtout si ton métier est une
passion
combien de drames et si je fais trop
juste en fait je fais juste 30 ans je me
dis ah le doute et la suite en train de
remplacer start in chaîne you to please
oui c'est pour m'amuser c'est vraiment
des souvenirs plus tôt mais harry est
réorganisé sa qualité
ouais c'est un petit peu aussi dit un
petit peu car ce gars marshall n'ont
cessé que l'application mes journées été
bissé beaucoup d'affaires mais si tu
sais ce que mayer est mangeurs ça
t'apprend le cdh équipe en fait pour que
tu réussisses tous en même temps parce
que tu es vraiment une qualité là dedans
parce que ces gens vis de ce programme
comme c'était les années hippies
on verra ouais mais c'est ça je me dis
imagine que ye li ju finalement bel et
en ce moment je m'entraîne comme une
truite george martin
dis moi dit consterné mais dans la
dernière année tu es plus que les essais
rapprochait puisqu'elle jouait comme
mais ces mines des carrières
si fish qui le choisissent l'arrêt
depuis on s'est approché des chats eux
j'aurais tellement dit commencer à me
focus est plutôt que c'est de donner
finalement si le tu peux commencer
vraiment à 16 ans parce que telle est
normalement à ce temps ci de l'année
c'est le début d'une saison
ouais facture tout dans le fond tu vas
faire une grosse saison là c'est toi
dans ta tête c'est en avril thé comme
des taupes chez walt en pestant in peace
highway
cependant si c'était quand tu goûtes à
la fin tu goûtes à maintenant je peux
avoir une finale c'est un goût amer
comme on dit je le veux pas comme en
dès que je laissais peut-être tout faire
pour pas que ça arrive mais en même
temps si a pas de jour je le savais pas
ce que je veux pas faire toi si tu veux
aussi quitté seul la tête haute c'est ça
pourrait de peau de george fait l'équipe
mais si au moins et au fait j'ai pris
les bonnes actions chez toi je suis
arrivée là je donne puisque je pouvais
finir comme garde vraiment je me dis
qu'est j'ai tout essayé sur ce sujet
mais je pense qu'on se doit ce tu te
dois ce vous vous devez mais c'est pour
ça qu'on a qu'on tenait derrière ce
parce qu'on se devait
on se doit nous mêmes une grande fin 90
à riez pas c'est que kg la réflexion ce
que j'arrête parce que leur est pas le
cas que qu'accueillant annoncé que les
un billet annulé pierre i am a dit à mes
4 on mérite mieux que ce qu'on mérite
mieux que de finir à une coupe québec n
ont eu qu à mougins
ville a dit on mérite pas se finir comme
sur un ace savoir que ça finisse ou que
c'est super de finir tu sais comme étant
les essais c'est
si vous faites pas l'équipe mais au
moins vous allez de monter sur le blog
pourquoi course il vous allez vraiment
laborieux parce que ce on s'ennuyait
tabarnak l'adrénaline de derrière le
bloc le dit c'est pas la graine de l'art
le bloc me tromper notre laquelle le
tenait un blog d'être copain portant
dans l'année le est vraiment la dernière
course quand tu sais que c'est ta
dernière à la quelque chose aussi
je repensais aux firmes du petit
l'adrénaline d'abord course c'est bon
j'arrête in anger j'avais 16 ans le tipi
j'ai pas d'enregistrer un niveau est
très élevé mais j'avais déjà oublié
c'était quoi là derrière le bloc
puissant c'est l'adrénaline pige à ces
instants à lui puis dans le film avant
l'épreuve le avant de régler sa mort ça
va ramener le gf106 fille pilotes
il était juste savoir maintenant sur le
blog qu'il était le fameux point de vue
des années des coups de tête en plan
large que tu vois le depor comme d'une
façon distance il sait comme des
supports sont là je l'avais jamais
oublier le jobbik existe elle est plus
qu'un jardin au jeté le fusil
[Musique]
décomplexés et 52,5 éventuellement fort
a fait ce métier moi ce que je me
rappelle aussi c'est que par exemple moi
sachant que j'avais accepté à concordia
c'était ma dernière année et une
notation tout autre copain porte chez
rexam années de natation tout est plus
le fun aussi de façon le dernier camp
d'entraînement
l'année d'avant ton camp d'entraînement
tout et été crucifié est-il tellement
pourquoi tu fais ça puis je me rappelle
spécialement jeter comme on dit que ma
dernière année moi j'ai plus apprécié et
moshavim mais dont la situation camp
d'entraînement compris que je vis mais
quand j'avais ma date finale que je
savais que ça finissait ce que je fais
de cinq ans d'université puis c'est fini
oshawa 15e anniversaire à sherbrooke qui
avait la date de ma course le team 220
les deux plus belles années toute ma vie
ça c'est fun genre de faire à chaque
fois
j'appréciais tout dans le processus les
camps d'entraînement tout tout tout
autre à qui je faisais aussi plus un peu
ce que je voulais le training plus à ma
tête
puis la mélasse pour seul effet que vous
je vous souhaite finalement c'est amuser
vous amusez vous majeur de passer vous
parce que c'est les deux sont liés mais
quand tu fais des bons sets puis des
bons entraînements puis des bonnes
compétences des trucs comme tu dépasses
il ya une vraie satisfaction dans ce
projet juste de s'amuser peut-être là la
ronde deux sens durant 14 semaines s'est
amusé sait nager vite phone house en
écriture plus en parler ouais bah c'est
vraiment c'est ça soit au xviie siècle
en 1500 trop près exact on fait un film
qui en fait déjà co écrit avec la
productrice de butterfly ce soir non
mais dominique mai 2010au est ce parce
qu'elle était une productrice n'est il
pas créative et à l'incompétence des
animations qui finit bien
bientôt tu jaguars ont co-écrit un film
sur les filles droit mais on veut
traiter un film historique un piètement
comme je me rends fait parce que c'était
vraiment raf nouvelle france
on ne va quand même pas qu'on nous vend
les pas les belles histoires des pays
des hommes dans all c'est des histoires
trafic pays-d'en-haut bâton puis le film
se battre essentiellement sur le bateau
fait que dans le fond mais on part à la
rochelle les 36 premières filles du roi
sans avoir discrètement comme situe pas
sur la lune j'aurais tout en bo1
c'est d'un mois et demi de traversée
transatlantique des gens morts le tarif
est ici comme juste d'imaginer devoir de
rencontrer tous genres des premières
nations au pi 2 et si c'est vraiment la
planète
c'est comme ça qu'on veut le traité mais
c'est que pour la petite histoire en
1163 les 36 premières fou du roi sur un
autre royales de louis xiv au pti pour
remettre la france en contexte le thé la
france était ravagé par la peste tout
l'argent partait adversaire puis il y
avait des guerres de religion en
protestant catholique fécamp qui
quittait la france qui t'aiment france
leur tri le genre fa qui s'en allait
pour un espoir d'avenir meilleur
les 36 premières sont ce bateau puis
l'affairé ça dure trois mois trois
semaines et trois jours
les provisions d'habitude comme je dis
allons traverser c'était deux mois et
demi accueillir 60 personnes qui sont
morts sur le bateau puis fait que ces
scores but de moving
[Musique]
voilà ce que tu es
qu'est-ce qu'on se trouve un bateau
d'époque et les ya des répliques de
frégate d'époque qui fait qu'on va
tourner tout ce qui est sur le pont va
être tourné en mer meetic pas besoin
d'aller en haute mer par exemple la
rochelle je pense qu'on veut le
d'ailleurs j'ai pris goût aux images de
synthèse prendre en compte qu'on est
capable de faire une folle au complet
attention c'est dangereux ça donne je
sais danser mais ce que je peux dire
c'est que je pense et c'est kenny oui
même si tu tournes à la rochelle pour
tourner le depor faut que tu siggi tout
le port de la rochelle qui contemporain
tout ce qui restait des deux tours de la
rochelle jean pierre je commente paul
icre et les deux tours en pierre c'est
parce que il ya une façon créative de
traiter l'image de synthèse depuis pense
pas que non plus le genre de cinéastes
qui nous fait mes propos mais sa facture
fac et voilà
puis cook excellent fait qu'on invite
tout le monde à les voir le diable de
fly si vous ne l'avez pas déjà fait puis
cette conversation là va faire beaucoup
plus de sens quand vous allez laborit
est tout à fait exactement exactement
fait que fait merci beaucoup
vous avez vu des hésitations encore pour
l'excellent travail
alonso nadia volf